donc bon soir toutes et à tous j'espère
que vous avez le moral
en général la première partie de ce que
je vais vous raconter donne un petit
goût mais je vais essayer de vous
expliquer que l'entente part d'énergie
en fait on parle de la totalité c'est ce
qui fait notre quotidien de ce qui a
fait notre passé de ce qui fait que l'on
attendait dans cette salle a disputé au
lieu d'être faire interner travail
éthique et en fait on parle
essentiellement dans tout ce qui vous
entoure
c'est pas comme ça malheureusement que
la majeure partie des débats s'engagent
à ce que je vais vous dire derrière j'ai
une réponse standard peut-être que dans
cette salle ce soir si je le pouvais
ckoi l'énergie kangourou et convier tous
curieux c'est possible cela étant quand
on pose la question à deux concitoyens
c'est pas ça le premier truc qu'il en
vient à l'esprit
alors qu'en général les débats sur
l'énergie quand vous regardez la manière
dont ils sont transcrits il ya un
élément qui ressort toujours très fort
très vite en particulier quand on
discute dans le monde économique c'est
que nrj c'est une affaire de prix et que
la bonne énergie ce qui coûte pas cher
le reste des considérations qu'on peut
avoir sur la question ou devenant un peu
accessoire est du reste historiquement
pour ne parler que d'une forme d'énergie
en tentant par a beaucoup ce soir
d'électricité historiquement tous les
pays du monde devront ajuster leur boîte
de production électrique sur ce qui leur
coûte le moins cher au moment où on a
des parts et l'électrification du monde
qui compte de contrepartie
environnementale
devenu beaucoup plus loin que ça non
plus tard aujourd'hui
quand on discute d'énergie cela étant
réduit à l'énergie à un prix c'est
réduire l'énergie à quelque chose qui
est très en dessous de son importance
réelle
la raison à cela c'est même si vous
trouvez très probablement dans cette
salle que les centres au rendement cher
l'électricité vont horriblement cher que
le gaz pour envie de manger etc
il n'empêche que quand vous regardez ce
que dépensent les habitants de cette
planète pour se payer leur énergique
donc en gros le pétrole le gaz le
charbon est ce qu'il ya derrière
eh bien ça ne représente en moyenne
mondiale que quelques courses entre ce
que les gens galerent si vous regardez
ce que coûte ce que le pétrole le
charbon et le gaz qui sont produites
chaque année sur terre
c'est juste quelques pourcents de ce que
les gens canine je vais vous donner un
autre pourcentage
je suis ici en train qu'en voiture ou
s'il faut dire à personne mais donc je
suis en train pour la sncf qui est le
premier consommateur d'électricité de
france
quand la sncf en sommeil tout seul 25%
de la production électrique française à
travers une société que vous connaissez
tête avec keolis qui a permis bus c'est
probablement un des premiers
consommateurs de carburants en france et
enfin la sncf est également que vous
savez le premier transporteur routier de
france au travers d'autres via tokyo 10
qui opère des camions dont keolis musée
aux dix plus les trains au diesel parce
qu'il y en a encore fait que la sncf est
aussi probablement à des produits
le carburant en france vient la sncf
dépenses seulement 3% de son chiffre
d'affaires dans sa facture énergétique
se montrant sans si vous retirez à la
sncf la capacité d'avoir de l'énergie
le chiffre d'affaires de la sncf tombe à
zéro depuis un trac avance plus un
puisque avance puis un camion qu'avance
quitte à faire des ronds si vous retirez
à la sncf trois concentre son chiffre
d'affaires se vante de cheminots vous
mettez à la porte
sa gueule pendant un mois au lit par
partie donc c'est pour montrer que la
part de l'énergie dans les dépendances
en fait ne reflète pas son importance
réelle dans le monde qui nous entoure
malheureusement ça va refléter le temps
passe c'est à dire qu'à partir du moment
où notre facture énergétique est pas une
grosse facture et bien l'expérience
montre que on va pas les passer
énormément de temps alors ici dans cette
salle je ne sais pas s'il ya beaucoup de
locataires ya beaucoup de locataires
dans cette salle gens qui louent leurs
logements
oui ou non il ya beaucoup de temps plein
air alors est ce qu'avant tout compris
des racques c'est dans cette salle que
des vieux
[Rires]
quand on pose la question dans le
quétaine tous les gens connaissent par
coeur le content de lui envoyer les
accédants stature
donc il ya des actions auxquelles on
s'est coincé attention donc là c'est que
ce soit une petite facture fait qu'on a
tendance à lui passé peu de temps et il
passé peu de temps ça veut pas dire que
c'est nécessairement pertinent est en
fait une bague que je fais souvent c'est
de dire c'est pas beaucoup plus
intelligent que de dire que parce que
notre cervelle
est ce de bon sens de notre masse et
bien oxygéné ne pas les augmenter ses
prêts graal n'en ayant ces deux
constantes notre masse et ados qualité
de notre corps dès qu'on est bien
l'énergie ce que je vais essayer de vous
montrer c'est que ça a beau être 3% de
factures nous 5 ou 10 pour un porte voix
1 200 fiches en fait sans qu'on s'en de
notre fils va demander quand je lis bien
100% de notre lima d'amendé alors dans
les choses dans les autres réflexes
pavloviens qu'on n'a pas faim à tokyo
lui évidemment qu'on a parfois en ce qui
concerne de l'énergie il y en a un
deuxième qu'il est il faut l'économiser
vous avez peut-être certains d'entre eux
vu dans entre ville et campagne de pub
de l'ademe ou vous explique que la
meilleure énergie est celle qu'on
consomme pas alors c'est perdu c'est
exactement l'inversé la meilleure
énergie de sa console ça fait très
exactement un siècle et demi qu'on dans
concept de plus en plus alors de deux
choses l'une où ça fait un siècle et
picon et les crétins patentés ou bien
une autre bonne raison au fait que
l'histoire soit comme
le troisième réflexe pavlovien
aujourd'hui est de dire bon très bien
d'énergie va faire 160 $ à 100 %
renouvelable c'est vachement bien
sauf que voilà un bateau ils sont
conscients de blabla pataude et quelques
siècles
alors ces faits en bois semblables avec
des voiles en coton et en lin 100%
renouvelable actionnées par des marins
100% renouvelable
c'est difficile car se serait produit
entre eux et ça avance sur un océan sans
qu'on s'en fout plein et on s'est dit
dans quand même pour faire venir les
t-shirts à celle que vous avez achetés
en soldes rapidement de là où ils ont
été fabriqués c'est vachement mieux
d'avoir une barrique fossiles dans qu'on
a facilité la marine on avait les
transports terrestres sans qu'on s'en
rende ou là vous voyez ici un animal un
cheval sans conscience dollars tirant
une charrette en bois 100 % renouvelable
vengeant de l'eab 160 blessés et on se
dit non quand même pour faire
fonctionner rapidement l'économie c'est
mieux d'avoir des transports fossiles
c'est plus efficace une agriculture 100%
renouvelable certains d'entre vous se
souviennent peut-être avec des livres
traitent d'affaires renouvelables
mangeant de l'air tout à fait anodin
mais en se disant en vain pour que le
macd aubry 7 à 3 à 3,4 euros c'est
vachement mieux d'avoir des tracteurs
fossiles c'est plus efficace
nous avions des travaux publics sans
qu'on soit renouvelable moyennant quoi
vous allez voir robben amant assez
longtemps et maintenant faire des ronds
points sont importants les ronds-points
et bien nous avons des travaux publics
s'enfonçant fossiles est
considérablement plus efficace on avait
une construction sans conscience de
blabla et à l'époque de la construction
était 100% renouvelable et bien
construisez pas une maison pour le prix
de quelques années de salaire ça
n'existait pas cette époque là quand on
rajoute les chambres à coucher l'espace
de glisse et les chapeaux et aujourd'hui
grâce à la construction quasiment 100%
fossiles et bien nous sommes capables de
construire le grand tour à la défense en
un an alors qu'il a fallu un siècle pour
faire notre dame en version de mac os x
10 5 ans seulement vous allez ici une
industrie 100% renouvelable
c'est à dire le droit aux aubois n'a
actionné par un de los andes où l'art et
c'est l'europe et découverte de boulin à
eau et à vent au moyen-âge un cd avec ça
que l'on donné la force motrice atteint
2,7 et puis on se dit non quand même
pour faire en voiture pour pas cher
parce qu'elles ne sont pas cher de le
voir c'est quand même beaucoup mieux
d'avoir une industrie essentiellement
faut aussi que ça marche mieux et on
avait mettre des séchoirs luzerne
renouvelables ça fait pas le soleil et
aujourd'hui on a deux séchoirs accusé un
fossile de poisson
donc ça fait deux siècles que on passe
notre temps à passer de 100 concerts
double arbre à autre chose que sans
conscience double à bhl est donc la
raison de la question c'est pourquoi on
a fait ça à nouveau est ce que on était
des andouilles puisque erding l'aps
vachement bien ou est ce que il ya une
raison à ce qu'on ait fait ça soit dit
en passant depuis qu'on dit que les
renouvelables c'est très bien c'est pas
pour autant que ce sont les
renouvelables qui dans le monde se sont
développés le plus rapidement que vous
avez ici un graphique d'opportunités
parce que ça parle beaucoup d'importance
dans lequel j'ai représenté et pour
chacune des énergies monde utilisent
aujourd'hui dans le monde
la différence entre la consommation
annuelle en 2000 et la consommation
hagen
18 donc chaque barre de ce graphique
représente la croissance de la quantité
d'énergie consommée énergie par énergie
dans le monde en fonction de l'énergie
qu'il s'agit alors même si c'est en
anglais mais ce sera compliqué pour vous
de reconnaître que là on a le charbon le
pétrole ou le gaz pour les précités
raisonnablement facile à dire et bien ce
que vous constatez c'est que sur les 18
dernières années
depuis l'an 2000 mais si vous avez fait
ça depuis l'an 2010 aurait des tours
break est bien l'essentiel de
l'accroissement de l'énergie en
utilisant le monde sait des énergies
fossiles
donc c'est pas parce que on en parle
beaucoup que l'on en fait et pour être
plus précis sur les chiffres sur cette
période là le charbon a augmenté 10 fois
plus vite en gros que le solaire est
demandé dix fois plus que solaire est
cinq fois plus que l'éolien ce qui veut
dire que si le journal avec ont vocation
de représenter les faits et rien d'autre
bien moins d'articles qui vous parle du
solaire il devrait y à l'amortissement
du charme c'est très exactement ça qui
devrait se passer si ça reflétait ce qui
s'est vraiment passé dans l'aude
évidemment ce n'est pas exactement ça
que moi donc
l'énergie n'est pas juste une facture en
fait souvent sait pas exactement du tout
on n'a pas économisé on est sorti et
renouvelable est alors la raison pour
laquelle on a fait ça parce que je vais
vous expliquer maintenant c'est qu'en
fait l'énergie c'est ce qui nous a
transformés en iron man ou en superman
ou en superwoman pour de voile donc
c'est très exactement ça l'énergie c'est
ce qui nous permet tout et superman ou
super woman est quand même en trouve ça
vachement sympa et on n'a pas envie de
s'arrêter
pourquoi est-ce que l'énergie 2 a
transformé en superman pour ça je vais
revenir un tout petit peu de physique
élémentaire fait désolé de vous rappeler
des bancs d'école en passer par là
l'énergie avant d'être un motif de débat
absolument passionné avant d'être une
facture vraiment d'être quoi que ce soit
comme slogan publicitaire
c'est une grandeur physique que ça qu'il
est important de garder en mémoire c'est
que l'énergie c'est une en afrique
l'énergie c'est la grandeur qui sert aux
physiciens à décrire le changement d'un
système ou plus exactement à le
quantifier donc l'énergie
c'est ce qui permet de dire que quelque
chose a changé quand quelque chose
changer d'énergie qui intervient comme
ça qu'ils disent y siens décrit le
changement alors dans un certain nombre
d' actes de la vie courante on voit bien
que l'énergie introduit un changement
que par exemple à vous avez un appareil
à refroidir et 1
il a réchauffé s'est introduit un
changement c'est que ça change de
température et sa utilisent de l'énergie
là vous avez des objets faire des
machines qui permettent de changer une
vitesse typiquement ou à peu près tout
sur ceux qui sont venus ici en vélo
c'est très bien tous les autres vous
êtes venus ici dans une machine à
changer une vitesse qui s'appelle une
voiture vais aussi mais il utilise moins
d'énergie
là vous avez une machine à changer une
forme et soit dit en passant tous ceux
d'entre vous ici qui ont un tracteur
avec une charles derrière c'est possible
machine à changer une forme encore
changer la forme du sol et sa utilisent
de l'énergie
là vous avez des machines à changer une
composition chimique ça s'appelle une
usine de produits chimiques
ici vous avez une machine qui utilisent
l'interaction entre des électrons et un
champ magnétique
ça s'appelle un moteur électrique
symétriquement un alternateur donc vous
avez un changement vous alliez du
mouvement et un champ magnétique
vous vous retrouvez avec du courant où
vous aviez du courant et un champ
magnétique et vous retrouvez du
mouvement cela dépend dans quel sens
vont l'utiliser ici vous avez une grosse
grosse grosse machine à créer un
rayonnement qui changea tout petit peu
les choses puisque c'est notre
principale source d'énergie directs et
indirects
le soleil donc c'est une grosse bombe
thermonucléaire permanente dans laquelle
vous avez un changement en l'occurrence
le changement c'est la composition
atomique là vous avez encore un
changement dû à l'énergie de bronzage
activité extrêmement importante à
compter du 1er juillet
c'est à nouveau un changement qui se
caractérise dans tout transfert de
rayonnement à la matière et l'autre
changement que vous avez dans le
transfert du rayonnement la matière ce
multi cassions des smartphones dont on
peut plus se passer aujourd'hui c'est
également quelque chose qui utilise une
interaction
physique donc ces quelques exemples sont
là pour montrer que en fait quand on
parle d'énergie on parle de changement
et compter l'énergie pour un physicien
c'est juste compter le changement c'est
juste ça de là vous comprenez de choses
il peut pas y avoir des énergies propres
puisque à partir du moment où vous
utilisez de l'énergie ont changé quelque
chose en vous savez que être propre et
laisser les toilettes dans l'état dans
lequel vous les avez trouvés en france
c'est à dire d'avoir touché à rien or
l'énergie
c'est justement avoir changé quelque
chose donc l'énergie propre
ça ne peut pas exister très souvent on
remarquera que ce qu'on appelle énergies
propres en fait c'est juste des énergies
qui sont utilisés à des niveaux
tellement microscopique que leurs
inconvénients sont aussi microscopiques
mais dès que l' usage de ces énergies 16
des micros scopique en fait leurs
inconvénients s'associer être des pros
scopique et l'énergie cette épreuve
quelle qu'elle soit et de même il
n'existe pas d'énergie verte n'existe
pas d'énergie rosine et dans ce pays qui
est pas des régimes argenté et il
n'existe pas d'énergie à damier verte et
bleue les berges de sept changements à
chaque fois qu'on utilise l'énergie ont
choisi ces avantages et on choisit ses
inconvénients
est ce qu'on est capable d'arbitrer
quand on passe d'une source d'énergie a
eu d'autres c'est d'arbitrer les
avantages et les inconvénients il ya
toujours des avantages est toujours d un
comédien
deuxième chose essentielle en ce qui
concerne l'énergie c'est que l'énergie
est soumise comme toutes les grandeurs
physiques
des lointains ne dépendent pas de nous
alors c'est très désagréable pour les
hommes politiques et les fins politiques
ça demande un truc qui dépendent pas de
sa désir est de considérablement
donc on passe notre temps à l'assemblée
nationale a essayé faute et des doigts
contredisent les lois de la physique
on pourra pas marcher puisque contredire
les lois de la physique donc les lois de
programmation sur l'énergie que j'ai vu
depuis que je m'intéresse à ce sujet
sont toutes des tentatives répétées de
violer la physique où il règle de trois
et comme la physique ils arrivent
d'autres foires sont plus forts que les
désirs des légendes et des citoyens et
des électeurs et des élus saint martin
la vie l'énergie pardon comme toutes
grandeurs physiques qui se respecte à
des lois qui débordent pas ton est alors
y en a une qui est très importante que
j'appelle la loi garantit harry potter
donc la loi sans rien coûter à la
hauteur c'est une loi qui en physique
s'énonce comme la loi de conservation
c'est une loi qui dit que dans un
système qu'ils communiquent pas avec
l'extérieur
vous ne pouvez pas avoir
créations/destructions d'énergie corps
je l'appellerai pottoks d'harry potter
lui c'est ça la loi de conservation dit
si vous avez un système totalement
coupée de l'extérieur
la quantité d'énergie qui contient est
rigoureusement constante au cours du
temps ça veut dire quoi cette histoire
ça veut dire que si les hommes ont peu
de pouvoir consommer accéder à de
l'énergie
ils peuvent pas la craie en leur sein
tout ce qu'ils peuvent faire si elle est
à chercher dans l'environnement de la
baule existe déjà
donc en fait consommer de l'énergie en
pratique c'est aller chercher l'énergie
dans l'environnement cloud par un truc
qui s'appelle un convertisseur alors un
convertisseur c'est quoi historiquement
c'est nous dourgne un programme 10h
d'énergie donc le convertisseur
d'énergie c'est que vous rentrez dans
votre gare kabel quelque chose qui se
venge et puis accessoirement l'été vous
profitez en direct de la chaleur
et de là vous allez ressortir deux
choses qui sont du mouvement un peu de
la chaleur vous dans les animaux à sang
froid vous sortez pas beaucoup de
chaleur et beaucoup de mouvement c'est
pour ça qu'ils ont besoin de moins
manger debout pour se déplacer variés
mais par contre ils ont besoin d'habiter
dans un endroit où est donc le premier
convertisseur historiquement qu'on a
utilisé ces nouvelles sommes notre
propre interface et puis commander des
animaux un peu ambitieux surtout quand
on fait la politique comme on est les
avirons un peu ambitieux et que on aime
bien maîtrisé notre environnement on
s'est dit solidaire de propre record
c'est pas terrible de ne point faire
mieux et on a compris qu'on pouvait à
servir notre profit alors soit le corps
de noé pays s'appelle décalage soit le
corps d'autres convertissant biologique
ça s'appelle la domestication des
indices gros donc on a commencé à
domestiquer un certain nombre d'autres
êtres vivants et ainsi on peut accroître
notre capacité de transformation
environnement et bien prêt vous essayez
tout ça est pas terrible on est capable
de faire mieux c'est là qu'on a commencé
à exploiter les énergies renouvelables
pour ce que déboule en avant la
poursuite des moulins à eau ont
construit des forges avec le bras et là
on a encore accru de capacité de
transformation de l'environnement avec
dodo convertisseur déboule un des forums
etc
et puis à ce moment sont arrivés wade
pape invite qui on dit vous n'avez
encore rien vu
laissez-nous faire don va vous mettre au
point le botteur et alors là et
d'arrivée la révolution industrielle
grâce au moteur d'abord au moteur à
vapeur vers le charbon vapeur est
ensuite le moteur à combustion interne
et c'est donc vers 10h mange une belle
énergie
nous on savait pas utiliser avant qui
s'appelle les combustibles fossiles
ce qui veut dire que quand on dit que
nous utilisons de l'énergie en fait il
faut varier une énergie et il faut
remplacer par machine
on va arrêter d'utiliser convertisseur à
partir de maintenant parce que nous on
n'a pas comme des machines
terminator sinon on n'est pas des
machines dont on va parler convertisseur
et on va remplacé par adam parr et
l'énergie est remplacé par machine parce
que en pratique dans le monde moderne
utiliser de plus en plus d'énergie est
utilisée de plus en plus de matches et
c'est très exactement ça que ça et plus
on utilise de machines plus on accroît
d'insectes aux toilettes plus on devient
superman
c'est très exactement ça alors pour
comprendre à quel point cette énergie
faramineuses par rapport à ce fait que
valider les machines des faramineuses
par rapport à celles de nos propres
records
on va imaginer les faire un exercice
alors que désolé dans le loudunais
malgré les qualités du lieu parce que ce
soit très facile de faire 2000 bêtes de
délivrer dans la journée donc on va
imaginer que vous aviez à parier qu'on
comptait s'y faire le cifa sur la tour
eiffel ou parce que ça c'est pour le
faire à pied évidemment dans l'ascenseur
ou que vous allez dans les pyrénées dans
les alpes ou sur le grand ballon
d'alsace faire ce genre d'exercice donc
imaginez vous que vous fassiez 2000
mètres de dénivelé dans la journée et
qui a tôt fait de 1000 mètres de
dénivelé 1 journée qu'il ait raison
quelques temps vous expliquer aux autres
en général quand on a fait ça on les
compare à de la soupe du soir on
considère que l'on a bien mérité
non pas que l'on ingère est bien quand
vous faites de millimètre de délivrer
dans la journée qu est ce qui se passe
aux jambes vont servir à glisser votre
corps contre le champ gravitationnel
c'est ça qui fait glisser votre propre
masse en altitude contre le champ
gravitationnel est bien de 1000 mètres
de dénivelé dans une journée
vous savez rien d'autre en termes
d'énergie restitué que ridicule demi
kilowattheure donc quand vous transpirez
toute une journée pour monter de 1000
mètres de dénivelé
toute l'énergie que vos jambes en est
capable
en janvier c'est un demi kilo watt heure
d'énergie mécanique si vous faite un
jour sur deux à la fin de l'année vous
aurez fondu de l'ordre de 100 kilowatts
heure d'énergie mécanique dont je vous
dis entendant une personne qui fournit
du travail de force avec ses jambes
tous les jours à la fin de l'année aura
fourni de l'ordre de 100 kilowatts heure
d'énergie mécanique c'est à dire 100
kilowatts heure de transformation du
monde puisque je vous ai dit que
l'énergique c'est une capacité à
transformer le monde
imaginons maintenant que vous soyez
ouvriers des travaux publics a saisi des
crampes et que vous des caissiers six
mètres cubes de terre dans la journée si
l'étude de cas ça fait quinze tonnes 15
tonnes remontée d'un mètre se trouve que
malgré les ans tous les deux tours de
reins ça fait dix fois moins d'énergie
que l'énergie reculent de la paire de
jambes
c'est à dire 100 gagne 0 5 kilowatt
heure quand vous faites ça et si vous
faites ça un jour sur deux à la fin de
l'année vous aurez restituer 10
kilowatts heure d'énergie mécanique donc
un nouveau travail de force
enfin bon travail de force est capable
de modifier l'environnement à hauteur de
10 500 kilowatts heure sur une année et
bien 10 kilowatts heure c'est le groupe
du de l'énergie thermique que vous
n'avez dans la combustion dames seules
litres de pétrole un solde qui vaut le
prix scandaleusement élevés la grosse
attente scandaleux dans un lit de
pétrole qui vaut le prix scandaleusement
élevé de main d'oeuvre 50
une fois que vous l'avez fait passer
dans un moteur vous ne récupérez pas la
totalité souvent d'énergie mécanique
là aussi la physique vous l'interdît de
transformer des chaleurs la charge
mouvement avec un enfant de 1 c'est pas
possible pour récupérer quand même 2 à 4
kilowatts heure d'énergie mécanique ce
qui veut dire que l'indécence qui passe
dans une bâche il apporta quelques
tracteurs un camion une voiture etc à
l'appel capacité à transformer
l'environnement que 10 à 100 jours de
travail de force d'un être humain un
litre de pétrole benzène
alors c'est pas comme si vous payez
autre travailleur au smic est
normalement c'est interdit tient moins
si vous faites pour un homme dit à
personne
vous allez payer votre kilowattheures
d'énergie médiatique quelque chose qui
se balade entre quelques centaines et
quelques milliers d'euros
si vous faites médéa kilowattheure vous
demander pardon à la machine de vous
fournir un kilowatt heure d'énergie
mécanique vous allez le payer quelques
dizaines de centimes c'est à dire de
quelques centaines à quelques milliers
de fois
donc pour tous ceux dans la salle qui
sont agriculteurs
la hausse du rendement des exploitations
elle est très exactement là la
multiplication par un facteur de sang de
la productivité agricole très exactement
londres c'est qu'en passant des ordres
tracteurs on a démultiplié ombre honda
qu'on vous a transformé en superman tour
de rêve dans superman pour de vrai pour
un don quand on dit de l'essence à 1.50
au cher on se fout le doigt dans l'oeil
jusqu'au plexus 1 dont 56 gratuit c'est
gratuit ce qui va nous coûter
c'est qu'on était du droit y est on sait
plus s'en passer c'est ça le problème
mais c'est gratuit et en fait c'est
justement parce que c'était gratuit
qu'on est au rendez vous n'a pas coûté
cher de vera wang et imaginons
maintenant que nous prenions un risque
grave c'est sauf cas très particulier on
crie pas sur les toits pas une vocation
de l'ess
ce qui veut dire que quand vous allez
prendre un esclave
vous allez devoir prendre quelqu'un
contre sa volonté
ce qui va beaucoup d'étapes dans le tour
il empêcher fiche le camp de voûte
russie d et c est tout ça va vous coûter
tard et bien quand vous regardez la
quantité de travail qui est capable de
fournir un être humain a mis en
esclavage hills vous vous rendez compte
que même un esclave pas vous coûter 10 à
100 fois plus cher que la machine qui
rouspètent pas et qui ne ce n'est pas
réel et qui travaille toute la journée
et a pas besoin de se retrouver et
d'innocence par d'autres aussi des
sauveteurs
les afghans donc le la raison pour
laquelle l esclavagisme a disparu dans
les pays qui ont eu accès à l'énergie
abondante
c'est pas du tout parce qu'on est devenu
bon alors qu'avant on était diabolique
on a exactement même code génétique ya
deux siècles c'est juste parce que ça
n'a strictement aucune espèce d'intérêt
deux antiquités à servir son voisin
alors que la machine considéré comme
parfaitement morale vous fait le lot
pour considérablement moins chers donc
cette pétrole caliskan c'est pas notre
déontologie et de moyens c'est juste le
métro je pourrais m'arrêter là quelque
part parce que la totalité de votre
pouvoir d'achat
le miam figure est hélas la liberté de
se déplacer en bagnole pour quelques
centaines de kilomètres pour pas cher
c'est là le fait que vous ayez 40
l'écart bail d'habitation fait c'est là
le fait que vous puissiez vous acheter
un tee shirt chez zara pour 10 euros
c'est là le fait que vous ayez la viande
dont le prix a été divisé par 100 en
l'espace de deux siècles
c'est là et c'est tout simple corps tout
ça et là nous vivons assis sur le
pétrole le gaz le charbon et plus
marginalement le nucléaire dans
l'électricité et d'autres trucs de cette
nature c'est là dessus que nous vivons
pouvoir d'achat il est là les
revendications de la cgt du medef sont
un tout et là je vais rentrer un peu
plus dans des tailles mais c'est
essentiellement ça qu'il faut retenir
alors cette énergie comme je le disais
tout à l'heure à perdre transformer les
gens que nous
ensuite parce qu'on s'est adjoint des
poux de carcasse à droite et la gauche
qui s'appelle des machines qui sont
totalement surpuissante par rapport à
mon être humain elle a tout à l'heure
qui des caisses de la terre ou qui
montent à l'assaut du mont blanc en fait
un petit calcul rapide vos montres que
il développe une puissance qui va d'une
petite à une grosse ampoule électrique
encore c'est ça la puissance qui
débloque en régime permanent ont pas dit
il est capable de faire un kilowatt pour
sa part réussi mais sinon quelqu'un de
normalement constitué sur quelques
heures il fait 10 à 100 watts
c'est ça qui fait la puissance mécanique
à l'exception qui dans la salle a déjà
vous l'idée de la soupe avec un mixeur à
soupe vous n'êtes pas non
la raison de santé vide est ce que vous
savez combien de cyclistes vous avez
dans la main quand vous tenez votre
victoire à soupe à 15
un peu moins quand même quatre autres
beach à l'aso qui fait 400 watts
il a donc la puissance de quatre
cyclistes en train de pédaler
c'est pas le même prix si vous deviez
avoir quatre employés de maison à l'aide
pour pédaler pour faire la sauce l
énergie gratuite
c'est ce que je vous disais l'énergie
gratuite qui dans la salle un tracteur à
jemappes imac intel
et bien quand vous avez un tracteur
entre les mains vous avez quelques
centaines de paires de jambes entre les
mains ou vous diviser par dix et vous
avez dans votre pool / 7
et vous avez le nombre de chevaux de
trait que vous avez entre les mains dont
quatre acteurs de 60 kilowatts
vous avez quasiment une centaine de
chevaux de trait entre les bains et vous
avez plusieurs centaines de paires de
jambes entre les mains évidemment nous
aussi pas même quand vous avez un engin
de travaux publics savent eux
développent la même puissance que l'été
il y ait deux paires de bras et c'est
grâce à ça je le redis qui ont fait le
point pour pas cher faveur au point
ainsi que les routes et voies de chemin
de fer etc
tout ça pour pas cher un camion [ __ ]
comme quelques milliers de fois les gens
de son conducteur et un avion comme a
billion fois les jambes du pilote pour
ça que pilote je vais payer et enfin un
habitant industriels comme le laminoir
de fos-sur-mer et bien il a la même
puissance mécanique que si je donnais un
marteau à tous les franciliens en leur
demandant de marteler toute la journée
d'accord il faudrait que je mette 10
millions de franciliens au travail
rien qu'à marteler des tôles toute la
journée pour remplacer de l'habit noir
de fos-sur-mer qui est conduit à
l'instant où je vous parle par une
personne à l'ouvrier dans la cabine de
pilotage ventes en plus d'un très beau
costume de superman
donc voilà quelques voilà quelques
machines car à plein d'autres qui a déjà
passé un aspirateur êtes salon les
hommes jouent en garde
est ce que vous savez quelle est la
puissance d'un aspirateur un kilowatt 10
cyclistes d'accord on des respirateurs
dix cyclistes en train de pédaler se
connaissait la puissance de votre frigo
danser - général ces quelques dizaines
ne s'est pas beaucoup moins frigo 55
quelque 120 kilowatts heures sur la d
mais ça fait quand même à ou de schiste
voilà il ya des gens des censeurs et
qu'ils n'enquêtent pas celui d'un
ascenseur là c'est pareil vous avez
quelques kilowatts de puissance du
moteur donc là vous avez quelques
dizaines de cyclistes en train de
pédaler et c'est donc voilà à quoi
ressemble notre exosquelette évidemment
on est pareils rothbard avec les
vignerons milieu plat et un truc qui
fait caca ctaq mais on a vraiment
aujourd'hui un costume d'iron man qui
est l'empilement de toutes les machines
qui sont en train de travailler pour
nous à l'instant où je vous parle à la
fois des métiers à tisser des
raffineries des trains des camions des
bateaux des usines qui tournent des
trieuses des laminoirs accès à tout ça
quand un travail pour nous en ce moment
moyennant quoi nous on peut s'écouter
causés dans cette salle
au lieu de ça tout ça et ses esclaves
des temps modernes ou en plus l'énorme
avantage par rapport aux esclaves des
temps anciens soient les animaux
domestiques et soit les êtres humains
qui étaient concurrents vendent ou pour
manger
donc ils avaient besoin du sable pour
manger comme nous les animaux très à
l'époque où il y avait des animaux très
dans l'agriculture utilisait plusieurs
dizaines de pourcents que la surface
agricole moins d'emplois on finissait
par les manger dans la boucherie
chevaline
mais quand même il utilisait plusieurs
dizaines de pourcent de la surface
agricole qu'on pouvait pas utilisés pour
couvrir d
et bien exit les animaux de trait et
maintenant 100 % des surfaces agricoles
pour nourrir les hommes parce que deux
esclaves des temps modernes que l'on
mange du sous-sol au stade du sol en
sous sol ils nous ont laissé tout
l'espace aux surfaces et ses esclaves
des temps modernes
ils ont multiplié notre puissance
musculaire par un tracteur 200 en
moyenne mondiale
dit autrement si on n'avait pas les
machines est bien le même pib
la même l'économie mondiale il faudrait
1400 milliards de huf pour la voir
les 10 400 milliards d'euros concentré
évidemment pas aux rebelles et comment
les dons vient donc sans les machines
jamais nous n'aurions eu un système
économique comme celui que nous
observons aujourd'hui qui nous fait aux
vêtements pour pas cher dans mes enfants
pas cher et de groupes de lacq pour pas
cher
jamais on aura usé et en occident le
facteur multiplicatif c'est pas 2 ans et
6 ans donc chacun d'entre eux bronze et
sales ou inclus nous vivons en moyenne
comme si on avait multiplié la force
productive de dons brydon jean bart 6
ans et l'augmentation de la productivité
du travail cher aux économistes
on a constaté au xixème et xxème siècles
c'est pas parce que nous sommes depuis
chila avec 600 paires de bras à 600
paires de jambes c'est juste par votre
chambre ou une paire de bras les pères
blancs des provinces du centre ouest
c'est tout simplement parce qu'on s'est
adjoint la mixture on a notre coquille
d'escargot un peu spécial là qui est
constitué de toutes les machines qui
sont en train de travailler pour nous si
on était toujours au à l'époque du
moyen-age et bien le pib par personne
serait divisé par deux sens en gros par
rapport à aujourd'hui
en gros ça fait un peu mal à l'aise dans
ce foyer alors cette énergie ce moment
le 10 12 voici de quoi elle se compose
mondialement elle se compose
essentiellement de combustibles fossiles
entre on les appelle des combustibles
fossiles parce que dictionnaire
c'est possible il se trouve que le
charbon c'est un reste de fougères qui
ont poussé à l'ère du charbon le
carbonifère 300 millions d'années à peu
près et le pétrole et le gaz c'est des
restes de micro algues plancton qui ont
vécu dans l'océan n'importe quand en toi
ya cinq ans il ya 500 millions d'années
donc c'est vraiment des fossiles c'est
vraiment des fonctions comme cibles au
sol même en france nous avons un petit
peu de combustibles fossiles
alors qui n'a jamais lu entendu ou vu
dans un média que la france était un
pays tout nucléaire dont quatre
seulement dont quatre ans et un pays
tout nucléaire puisque c'est écrit dans
le journal
alors j'ai demandé à mes équipes à 44 de
faire ici un petit graphique ou en
fonction de l'endroit où se trouve la
machine donc là la chine fabrique un
objet dans une usine dans la machine il
sert à transporter quelqu'un ou quelque
chose elle est essentiellement sur les
routes
la machine est énorme travail hors
fabrication des objets qui s'appelle
cassiel là la machine est chez nous
s'appelle pays en ciel il à la machine
et dans les champs pas très loin des
champs ça s'appelle agriculture et pour
chacun chacune de ces catégories de
machines on habille ici en milliards de
kilowattheures l'électricité le gaz les
carburants que ces machines qu'on serait
donc on trompe il est où les
kilowattheures les uns sur les autres
électricité de gaz etc et je vais main
en cercle et tout ce monde utilise en
france qui provient des combustibles
fossiles et je vous pose la question ce
que vous pensez que notre pays et tout
nucléaire
ça doit pouvoir se discuter à tout le
moins
alors notre pays à l'évidence non pas
tout nucléaire
notre électricité est à dominante
nucléaire la focalisation médiatique est
admis dans le nucléaire par contrarie
c'est que notre pays d absolument pas
tout nucléaire et je vous montrerai été
un peu plus tard cet exposé que c'est
pas du tout nucléaire mais bien les
combustibles fossiles qui font que
depuis sarkozy
tous les présidents qui se sont succédé
à l'elysée cherche la croissance sans la
trouver et du reste de la trouveront pas
plus à l'avenir
et ce n'est pas dû aux ducs les airs
laissez bien dues aux combustibles
fossiles bien mais un peu plus tard
alors cette abondance énergétique a
totalement déformé la structure des
métiers vous avez ici l'endroit où les
gens travaillent sur deux siècles en
france en planque dans 18 cents là on
est quasiment aujourd'hui offre qui fait
partie la fin parce que ça a pas
beaucoup d'intérêt pour ce que je vais
vous raconter
vous voyez qu'il ya deux siècles
l'essentiel de nos ancêtres sont
agriculteurs paysans ça comme vous
voulez ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
qu'à cette époque là comme le premier
besoin c'est de te bouillir une personne
dans l'agriculture est capable de se
nourrir l insu de dix personnes qui fait
autre chose
d'accord il faut deux apiculteurs de mes
dix ans pour couvrir trois personnes
c'est ça que ça veut dire oui la
productivité extraordinaire
vous voyez que cette fraction des gens
dans l'agriculture
elle augmentera par la quantité d'or
dans l'agriculture augmente jusqu'en
alors pourquoi est-ce que ça vous
arrange jusqu'en 1850 parce que 1850
c'est le minimum forestier en france
c'est le moment du deuxième millénaire
où la couverture forestière et la plus
petite est donc la surface cultivable la
plus grande et à ce moment là la
productivité d'un agriculteur n'avoir
pas beaucoup avec les années donc si on
augmente les surfaces cultivables le don
d'agriculteurs augmente c'est aussi
simple que ça et puis après pour voile
etc ça commence à baisser
alors ça va s est ce que les surfaces
cultivées diminue rapidement sa baisse
parce que l'industrie naissante à cette
époque là va commencer à équiper les
agriculteurs avec des engins un peu plus
performants essentiellement des socs de
charrues
très à vitesse croissante et ça va
permettre de commencer à augmenter la
productivité agricole notamment en
développant l usage d un dico de trêve
donc les animaux et convertisseurs
biologique remplacent les hommes et il
ya de moins de moins de moins en moins
de gens qui vont travailler dans les
champs
et puis après guerre alors la remplacent
les chevaux par des tracteurs et banzaï
c'est parti on multiplie la productivité
agricole par quasiment 10 ceux d'entre
vous les plus anciens s'en souviennent
les rendements céréaliers à l'est quitte
à en france en 1945 qu'on mettait enfin
des bugs année ça se balader entre 15 et
20 quintaux à l'hectare
aujourd'hui sur les meilleures terres
françaises ce sont les innocents donc
vous voyez on a multiplié les rendements
céréaliers par sept et en fait ce
quasiment sans hidalgo 75 80 il a pas
beaucoup augmenté depuis donc en
l'espace de trente ans à cause de
l'éruption dans les champs des tracteurs
les engrais azotés effet à partir du gaz
c'est à dire des hydrocarbures des
phytosanitaires c'est à dire à nouveau
de la pétrochimie dont pétrole pour les
tracteurs gaz pour les engrais azotés et
pétrochimie et à devaux pétrole pour la
potasse et de phosphates qui viennent de
quelques minutes dans le moment donné
qui ensuite sont baladés partout sur la
surface de la planète et du pétrole les
combustibles fossiles des boules
directement dans les chambres et vous
avez un effondrement de du nombre de
gens qui travaillent dans l'agriculture
tous remplacés par des tracteurs et des
usines auraient moyennant quoi on mange
qu'on est aujourd'hui beaucoup plus de
viande et on a beaucoup plus de
productions agricoles qu'on en avait à
cette époque là et on doit ça au magic
la question de savoir si l'on peut
nourrir huit ou neuf milliards de
personnes sur terre avec la fraction de
viande qu'on a aujourd'hui dans
l'alimentation dans un monde sans
combustible possible ne se pose même pas
par exemple c'est donc sans l'ombre
d'une hésitation
aujourd'hui du mans jean du pétrole un
kilo de boeuf à l'été donc armure c'est
le diesel du tracteur pour en cultiver
les céréales
20 plus de gaz les anglaises ont à peu
près l'équivalent d'un kilo de pétrole
qui dépasse ses machines
on vient pas dans les champs on les a on
va également en avoir de plus en plus
dans un secteur qui s'appelle
l'industrie avant l'industrie c'est quoi
ces des machines qui servent à extraire
des ressources de la croûte terrestre
les minerais des pierres et les
transformer à autre chose
d'autant qu'une autre c'est à dire des
boutons plus tout un tas d'autres trucs
moins indispensable et c'est à ce moment
se développent des emplois qui sont les
emplois d'ouvriers et qu'est ce que
c'est qu'un emploi d'ouvrier
si vous avez vu métropolis ou des temps
modernes vous en souvenez c'est en fait
un emploi d'auxiliaire des machines
c'est ça un emploi d'ouvrier
c'est un emploi d'auxiliaire des
machines pour appeler charlot dans les
temps modernes
c'est très exactement ça donc puis la
chine puis à d'emplois d'ouvriers donc
l'énergie permet d'augmenter le nombre
de machines en service dont nous permet
d'augmenter l'emploi industriel après
les chocs pétroliers
il s'est passé quelque chose que je vous
montrerai un peu plus tard qui est que
la quantité d'énergie par personnes
s'arrêtent de croître dans les pays
occidentaux et en particulier en france
l'énergie par personne vers la quantité
de machines par personne ont été
rapidement ça s'arrête de prendre par
contre la taille et la magie des entités
d'augmenter avant vous aviez comme dans
les temps modernes tout un tas d table
sur une chute de production qui était
faite par les ouvriers après que vous
avez eue ligue robotisée avec un seul
ouvrier dessus donc la taille de la
machine augmente beaucoup et à ce moment
comme la taille qu'il avait agi demande
beaucoup mais que la quantité d'énergie
totale ne prend pas beaucoup et bien
vous avez une diminution de l'emploi
industriel
ça n'empêche pas
industrielle ont continué à augmenter
elle a doublé entre 74 et 2007
on a fait moins de chance est des plus
d'airbus mais à double et puis à ce
moment là apparaît une catégorie
d'emploi supplémentaires si l'on peut
dire que les chômeurs
c'est à dire que personne au travail
dépend de tellement d'énergie est devenu
tellement productive que ya déjà plus à
ces espaces sur terre pour mettre tout
le monde au travail partout dans les
pays occidentaux le chômage arrive au
même moment
donc ce n'est pas dû à l'incurie d'un
personnel d'un personnage politique qui
aurait particulièrement mal géré la
situation en france pendant qu en
allemagne ça allait très bien le chômage
dans tous les pays occidentaux pendant
et depuis cette époque il n'y a que
trois manières de gérer la situation
vous laissez les gens au chômage ça
c'est la situation française en
indemnisant vouloir botter le cul pour
qu'ils aillent travailler contre x rien
ça c'est la situation inverse était de
mauvaise et la situation allemande est
intermédiaire entre les deux alors ce
que vous voyez ici en historique c'est
que pluie à d'énergie - agriculteurs
plus il ya d'énergie plus il ya
d'industrie et puis à l'énergie plus il
ya de service pourquoi parce qu'une fois
que vous avez beaucoup d'énergie vous
fabriquer beaucoup d'objets faut les
vendre pour les financer pour les
administrés pour en faire la pub faut
les compter sur des consultants inutiles
comme aux autres conseils etc tous ces
gens là sont des administrateurs d'un
monde compliqué dans lesquelles il ya
des flux physiques dans tous les sens à
l'évidence les emplois de services
dépendent des emplois industriels et
agricoles
il ne peut pas survivre sans l'idée
d'une économie dématérialisée on serait
tous dans un bureau avec le pli du
pantalon impeccable c'est des foutaises
ça ne peut pas arriver quelque chose
comme ça et je vais vous donner un
exemple si demain matin je supprime la
fabrication des voitures de fabrication
le sucre et les voitures d'emplois
industriels mais je n'ai plus besoin de
vendre des voitures en tout les gens
dans les banques qui sont du crédit
automobile au chômage j'ai plus besoin
d'assurer les voitures tous les gens qui
dans les compagnies d'assurances travail
suppressions en centre-ville au chômage
tous les moniteurs d'auto écoles qui
sont dans les services au chômage les
gens qui conçoivent les manuels pour les
auto-écoles au chômage les gens qui font
la pub pour les manuels pour les
auto-écoles au chômage et les gens qui
font la plupart les voitures surtout au
chômage dont tf1 au chômage les termes
que vous voyez il ya tout un tas il ya
tout un tas d'activités de services s'en
va relancer du vent ou évidemment tous
les gens qui apprennent à réparer une
voiture sont également au chômage
donc vous voyez tout un pan des services
dépend en fait du flux industriels sous
jacents et vous pouvez pas le détacher
et en fait vous pouvez prendre n'importe
quelle catégorie d'emploi service vous
avez derrière des flux industriels sous
jacents et vous ne pouvez pas détacher
les emplois services les flux
industriels sous jacent donc ce qu'on
est d'arriver à faire ses affaires un
peu plus de services par flux
industriels sous la cendre
c en est arrivé à faire mais faire que
des services en plus industrialisés
juste impossible
ça n'a aucun sens c'est un peu comme les
économistes lisent dans l'agriculture
ces deux concerts du pib donc on peut
s'en passer et un à trois canaux clean
si on mange plus le reste on a un peu de
mal à survivre donc c'est pas parce que
l'agriculture fait de pension du pib que
tout restant des pandas et bien c'est
exactement pareil pour les services et
servi 7 aces 70% de l'emploi mais en
attendant ils dépendent haute qualité du
fait qu'il y ait des flux industriels
sous jacent sinon il n'a plus alors tout
ce que j'ai pour à monter on peut le
retrouver ailleurs dans le monde
de souffrir de faim ici vous avez un
premier graphique dans lequel vous avez
chaque point bleu représente un pays
dans le monde et je représentais
en abscisse la quantité d'énergie par
personne et ont ordonné la part de
l'agriculture dans mon coin et bien ce
que vous voyez de rien extrêmement clair
c'est que plus vous avez d'énergie par
personne - iliad agriculteurs dans mon
coin
c'est extrêmement clair et ça c'est une
photo en 2013 pour tous les pays du
monde
donc je regarde n'importe qui n'importe
quel pays dans le monde qui convient pas
d'énergie par personne toi je vais dire
degré qu'il est l'attraction de la
population active qui travaillent dans
l'agriculture
vous avez exactement la même chose pays
par pays en séries chronologiques alors
ici vous avez pour le port le monde
la fraction des gens qui travaillent
dans l'agriculture en ordonnée donc plus
vous allez vers la droite plus
importante
et si vous avez à vendre pas la quantité
d'énergie consommée par personne les
émissions co2 par personne qui en gros
vous donne la quantité d'énergie fossile
consommée par personne la même chose et
les points support technologique et bien
vous voyez que de 1991 à 2014 on a
augmenté les émissions de co2 donc la
quantité d'énergie par personne et du
coup on a baissé les emplois agricoles
dans l'ensemble de
de la population active mondiale pour un
certain nombre de pays c'est
particulièrement spectaculaire voyez par
exemple pour la regarder ici pour la
chine
en gros plus vous avez de gens ailleurs
que dans l'agriculture et que vous avez
d'énergie qu'on se fait par personne ce
qui veut dire soit dit en passant que
quand on va baisser
l'approvisionnement énergétique de la
france parce que ça ne plaise ou pas de
toute façon ça va baisser parce que je
vais vous expliquer toute façon que ça
nous président thein sein a b c est bien
ça veut pas dire qu'on va tous être dans
un bureau à taper le carton
ça veut dire qu'une fraction croissante
des gens vont devoir retourner dans les
champs et recommencer à travailler avec
leurs mains c'est ça que ça veut dire
alors plus je vous ai dit tout à l'heure
aussi plus on and energy qui rendent
quelques bars plus il ya de gens dans
les services contrairement à l'idée
qu'on peut s'en faire
alors c'est exactement la même chose que
je vais vous montrer sur cette course
ici vous l'avez la part de la population
active dans les services pour le monde
dans son ensemble est ici les émissions
de co2 par personne c'est à dire
l'énergie utilisée par personne en
première approximation et bien vous
maniez avec le temps quand on
d'augmenter émission quand on augmente
plus exactement la part des services
dans l'économie ça veut dire qu'en fait
on va augmenter les émissions de co2 par
personne donc là aussi une économie
dématérialisé c'est pas que l'économie
de services
c'est une économie au service de l'art
étonnant mais une économie dématérialisé
c'est une économie avec peu alors voilà
quelques pays où là aussi c'est
particulièrement spectaculaire voyez la
chine
voyez le brésil en faisant du plus
quelques-uns toujours pareil
tous les pays émergents berck et points
il faut savoir que ça ça se passe à la
campagne mais ces emplois et ses envois
lama se passe en ville
donc quand vous augmenter
l'approvisionnement énergétique
personnes vous augmentez aussi autre
chose qui est la part de la population
urbaine
beaucoup de gens dans les villes
contrairement là aussi à quelque chose
qui est souvent dit comme avec la smart
estime à chaque semaine sa grande
énergie
en fait le simple fait qu'ils existent
que beaucoup de gens se combinent c'est
la marque d'une grosse consommation
énergétique
parce que ça veut dire que les gens les
machines travaillent à deux places pour
faire pousser la nourriture les vaches
il travaille à votre place quand
fabriquer tous comportent tous qu'on
utilise tout objet etc
il ya des camions dans tous les sens
pour acheter pour acheter les objets en
question de la boisson faite derby ville
où les gens à quitter demain matin si je
supprime les camions en france les
quatre cinquièmes des parisiens leur de
fond littéralement de faim parce que
avec des charrettes à bras gauche trop
vous n'êtes pas capables d'acheminer la
nourriture dont les gangs
quotidiennement besoins en provenance de
deux jours ou trois joueurs de transport
même avec des boulonnais qui ont été
faits pour emmener les huîtres font pas
les huîtres j'ai parfois le poisson
depuis dunkerque
bref donc ça veut dire que plus il ya
l'énergie créative et c'est exactement
ce qu'on va retrouver comme évolution
structurelle donc ici vous avez pour le
monde dans son ensemble toujours sa
suivante en deux logiques la part des
gens qui habitent dans les villes et ici
les émissions de co2 par personne à ce
que vous voyez c'est que au cours du
temps quand les émissions co2
ça veut dire que la part des habitants
dans les villes augmentent est en gros
c'est particulièrement vrai pour des
pays qui sont dits émergents donc en
gros quand vous avez plus d'énergie
plate machine se mette au travail
les campagnes se vident les gens vont
dans les villes où ils occupent des
emplois de bureau pour donner des ordres
aux machines alors on peut également se
balader partout quand on a plein
d'énergie ici vous avez le parc
automobile en france depuis la fin du
19e siècle comme le début du xxème roi
dire envoyer avant gaillard y en avait
quand même beaucoup après guerre on peut
en moins soit dit en passant par l'utp
lui qui avait été cassée mais vous voyez
que on a deux à trois millions de
bobines à ce moment là aujourd'hui en a
merci de pétrole ici vous avez sous les
yeux l'essor de la quantité de pétrole
utilisé par personne et voilà sur les
deux franchises désolé de lui sortir
avec de france il aurait fallu que je
cherche la carte de ce qui s'est passé
dans la région mais ici sur l'île de
france vous allez la distance domicile
travail en 1975 d'envoyer là aussi blanc
s'avère que les gens se déplacent peu à
pied à vélo
à pied à vélo ou scooter et là ils sont
urbains là il bouge un peu mais pas trop
et la même chose à la fin du xxème
siècle l'énergie a profondément modifié
l'urbanisme donc l'énergie a guidé les
campagnes fait grossir les villes et
étaler ces dernières et c'est quelque
chose que vous observez dans tous les
pays qui ont eu accès à l'énergie
tous pourtant dix ans ils ont suivi
exactement la même évolution en ce qui
concerne l'aménagement du territoire les
campagnes se vident et les villes
grossistes et senna alors cette énergie
elle déforme également la façon dont ils
font penser l'économie
vous avez ici les conneries que vous
avez apprise à l'école en cette vidéo
comme la physique vous avez appris un
peu déglingué à l'école de suture
plusieurs dans cette salle c'est un lieu
dans des codes qui c'est quoi c'est un
système productif qui est limitée par
deux facteurs d'évidentes 50 devant
l'école qui sont le travail et capital
et donc si vous avez suffisamment le
travail insuffisamment capital et bien
le supermarché alors un tout petit peu
de bon sens vous fait également vous
dire que pour que le supermarché soit
remplie il est bon ton d'avoir une
ressource qui vont permettre de faire le
produit supermarché parce que tous les
produits vous pouvez acheter au
supermarché
tous les produits que vous pouvez voir
cette salle tous les produits de
gouverner de votre naissance à votre
mort
ça n'est rien d'autre que des ressources
naturelles transformé par votre activité
donc il faut les ressources naturelles
sans ressources naturelles y a pas de
système de production les par ailleurs
il faut une capacité à les transformer
c'est ça qu'on appelle le travail est ce
que je vous ai dit juste avant c'est que
en moyenne mondiale n'ont aucun point et
les machines comme pour 210 autrement ce
qui fait l'essentiel du travail de
transformation quatre sources
aujourd'hui c'est les machines c'est pas
vous qui faites le verbe cette fois vers
c'est pas vous qui transportait des
marchandises
c'est le camion et sans vous faire
insulte c'est pas vous qui cultivait ses
lecteurs donc aujourd'hui c'est les
machines qui produisent les machines
sont évidemment totalement déterminant
par rapport à nous il ya également de
capital le capital il se fait exactement
la même manière le capitalisme vert en
transformant la source par exemple cette
salle des fêtes qui sait du capital que
ça suce pas quand on s'en sert
normalement ça c'est faudrait prendre
et bien c'est fait exactement comme le
reste avec des ressources naturelles
transformer la seule différence c'est
que ça s'use pas quand on s'en sert qu'à
la différence de la longueur de la
complète rangé et bien cette salle des
fêtes reste vous comprenez dans cette
affaire si j'ai plein de gens pour
travailler et des banquiers très
généreux mais quand il s'agit des
talents pour remettre le sang et l'odeur
des financiers mais qu ils vous mentent
de l'énergie eh bien vous comprenez qu'à
ce moment l'énergie devient un facteur
limitant du système et il vous manquera
de la production même si vous avez des
tas de gens prêts à travailler et même
si vous avez des investisseurs très
généreux et s'il vous manque des
ressources naturelles vous aurez aussi
un manque de production dont l'économie
est certes limitée par la pratique de
ces facteurs du temps mais aujourd'hui
ça n'est ni les hommes il ya du chômage
partout hélas trop ni les investisseurs
il ya d'argent partout on sait pas quoi
faire pour ça que les prix de tout et
n'importe quoi augmente aujourd'hui ce
qui est devenu le facteur limitant
d'économie c'est l'énergie et en
ressources et en premier lieu l'énergie
ce que je vais vous montrer dans
valentin vous avez ici la reconstruction
du pib mondial depuis la naissance de ce
hit the strikes en 0 alors ce que vous
pouvez remarquer c'est que
pendant la première moitié cependant le
premier millénaire
la question de la croissance dans des
débats électoraux n'était pas un sujet
puisque et pas de croissance
vous remarquerez qu'il n'y avait pas de
dépasser les taureaux et cette remarque
elle est tout sauf anodine je ne suis
pas du tout sûr que la démocratie va
facilement survivre un monde en
contraction
c'est pas sûr en tout cas je vous invite
à méditer
parce que moi les huit de mes craintes
est ce que je suis absolument certain
c'est qu'un monde en contraction pour
lequel on ne comprend pas que c'est ça
qui est en train de nous arriver
alors là c'est à peu près sûr qu'il va
nous arriver des pépins sur le plan du
système politique jusqu'en 1850
alors il ya la révolution agricole et
puis nos débuts de la révolution proto
industriels hors au moyen-âge qui
commence à créer un peu de croissance
mais toujours pas de choses et laharie
boîte et papa et son copain alors là et
on invente ce truc qui veulent s
toujours émerveillé le montant de
bêtises la croissance structurelle de
long terme mais sur une planète qui
faisait treize mille kilomètres de
diamètre ya deux siècles entre demi
kilomètre de diamètre aujourd'hui qui
fera toujours 13 10 km de diamètre dans
deux siècles et on a inventé la
croissance structurelle de long terme
merveilleux alors vous devriez pas
rigoler pour les plus jeunes d'entre
vous il ya un truc en ce moment c'est
vrai qu'entre moyens tout petit débat
sur les retraites ça vous dit vaguement
quelque chose
eh bien il ya un comité d'orientation
des retraites dans ce pays est ce que
vous savez quel est le taux de
croissance de l'économie qui présuppose
entre maintenant et 2050 pour faire ses
prévisions en deux pour rigoler de
consentement
pendant les 30 ans qui viennent alors
moi je parais toutes les économies avec
dieu dans cette salle transmissibles les
enfants que c'est évidemment pas ça
qu'on va avoir
mais c'est parce que les économistes ou
une croissance structurelle commentaire
je verrai ça a marché mais la question
c'est combien de temps et si je fais un
zoom sur la période récente
vous voyez qu'en fait le meilleur modèle
économique que je connaisse avec droite
et cette droite elle vous dit dis moi
combien d'énergie c'est-à-dire dis moi
combien de machines travaillent pour toi
et je te dirai quel est la production
économique
une simplicité biblique pourquoi
pensez-vous que la france
il y à quelques dizaines d'années avait
un pib supérieur à celui de la chine qui
était pourtant à l'époque dix fois que
le peuple est parce qu il ya eu une
époque courte
il ya eu une époque de l'histoire de ces
deux pays où la france a une plus de
machines pour la chine
donc on a eu les plus grosses économies
est plus rose
et puis la chine a rattrapé le taux
d'équipement en machine par personne et
craque et à passer dans tout conte c'est
aussi bête que ça aille dans ce jeu là
ne marche que tanks derrière
et donc vers une énergie c'est
exactement comme ça que ça implique donc
l'histoire est 19e et 20e siècles ce
point c'est nous avons des combustibles
fossiles super et ils sont gratuits
la tête commence à me 88 nous ils
pétrole et gratuit alors on va en parler
dans un petit moment
le vent est gratuit ça sent le vent
petit effort effectivement le point
gratuit
personne dans cette salle n'a payé un
centime pour le vent souffle et lien le
soleil ça ne va payer un centime pour
que le soleil est bien le pétrole est
parti parce que personne dans cette
salle n'a payé non plus un centime pour
que le pétrole existe personnes est la
raison pour laquelle le pétrole est
moins cher que le vent c'est tout bête
c'est que en fait quand vous payez de
l'énergie tout ce que vous payez s'il
est cousu main pour aller chercher
l'énergie qui est toujours gratuite dans
l'environnement est d'amener jusqu aux
hommes pour qu'ils en fassent quelque
chose et c'est toujours considérablement
moins chers de ce pc c'est le cas de le
dire pour faire un trou dans la terre et
sortir de pétrole qui est déjà pour
centrer pour nous par mère nature que
d'aller récolter une énergie qui fusent
et intermittente qui s'appelle le vent
ça poutre a toujours beaucoup moins cher
et c'est la raison pour laquelle on est
passé du vent au pétrole epal averses
c'est la raison pour laquelle il ya
quelques siècles on avait des moulins à
vent et quand on a découvert vous
pressez rue des trolles s'est servi du
pétrole pour parler argent quand vous
sortez un kilowattheure eu des ollières
d'aujourd'hui savent au goût de 40 à 50
euros du mégawattheures c'est à dire 4 à
5 centimes du kilowatt heure le pétrole
sort de terre à 0,3 centime le
kilowattheure
c'est la raison pour laquelle ont
dépassé des énergies renouvelables aux
énergies fossiles
alors c est vers cette fois ci wen
c'est leur principal deux fêtes elles
nous fournissent de l'énergie qui va
permettre de transformer tout le reste
sur terre et faire tous les objets qui
correspondent à nos désirs ou rouge noir
du voisin poisse qui nous excite le plus
et ça nous a pris un gi de bâtir le
système socio économique y est le nôtre
aujourd'hui dans l'hôtel on a des objets
à profusion on vit tous comme un nabab
parce que je t'ai trop choquer dans
cette salle les vaut tous autant que
vous êtes vous vivez mieux qu'un baron
du moyen âge tôt si vous avez moins de
pouvoir mais vous vivez matériellement
beaucoup mieux vous vivez beaucoup plus
longtemps
vous n'avez sont rarissimes exceptions
en francs l'hiver vous avez un carrosse
dans votre garage qui vous déplace à la
vitesse de l'éclair ce que le baron du
moyen-âge n'avait pas été fait ce qu est
ce qu sur son cheval vous manger de
manière beaucoup plus garanti dans
l'année vous avez les jeux du cirque
dans votre salon ça s'appelle i
télévision etc
vous vivez beaucoup mieux vous avez
toute votre presse qu'il voit pas la
différence
vous vivez considérablement mieux vous
allez me le pouvoir les voiliers
concernant les biens et les bergers cas
permettra et barrières comme l'énergie a
augmenté considérablement la
productivité du travail du coup on peut
travailler moins et ce travail en moins
on l'a affecté de pain de matières
différentes ont été remis des études
plus tard on prend sa retraite
ça aide quand sadate à retraite prière
alors la retraite généralisée
effectivement c'est après guerre mais
les premières retraite on était instit
instauré par col bayard pour les bas
rhin puis ensuite par bismarck pour les
militaires 3 et à l'époque où ça a été
instauré en fait c'était bien a ajouté
qu'il y avait trois personnes dans le
pays qui avaient dévissé les autres
déboires a donc nommé la retraite c'est
une façon d'affecter le temps libre
parce que les machines produisent pour
nous et sont capables de nourrir qui
compris ce qu'on appelle les inactifs
aux temps anciens les inactifs ça
n'existait pas à vous voyez une pomme ou
devenir inactifs on met des poteaux
parce qu'on n'avait pas de bouche
inutile de nourrir pour vous coller dans
les galères ces accords vont transformer
en machine mais ça n'existait pas de
nourrir des bouches inutiles
or aujourd'hui on n'a que ça à gauche
inutiles les retraités les gens qui
travaillent pas ensemble
les gens qui travaillent pas le week end
les gens qui travaillent pas le soir les
gens qui ne travaillent pas en dehors
des 35 heures
parce que le temps est ébauché dutil a
donné un mois comme beaucoup un peu
bizarre qu'on le doit aux machines donc
les machines
nous aurons aussi permis de satisfaire
les revendications conjointe du cg de la
cgt du maine est d'accord donc les
revendications de la cgt du mana de ces
machines
c'est l'énergie eon pas oublier notre ca
conserver alors tous à l'ipp labeaume ça
marche très bien dans mon infinie dans
un monde fini on finit par avoir de
petits sujets le premier est sec cette
combustion et free des habits dans
l'atmosphère ce qu'on appelle un gaz à
effet de serre c'est à dire car gaz qui
intercepte les infrarouges terrestre et
qui par ailleurs mais pas très longtemps
à s'en aller je vais vous dire pourquoi
ce qui a induit ce qu'on appelle le
changement climatique quand je vous
parlais un peu mais on a également un
goulet d'étranglement à l'avant dans
cette histoire c'est que les stocks de
combustible fossile datant gas 50 à 500
millions d'années qui sont pas
renouvelables peut pas dire on peut
aller bien qu'on tape dedans ça se
reconnaît comme quand on vit date
dilapidé un héritage au casino les gars
je reviens pas et bien ce que les d'être
amplement à la bombe aussi quelque chose
qu'il faut avoir en tête parce que
maintenant luce tbilissi ces mois de
transformation et donc moins de pib et
vous allez voir que c'est déjà à
l'oeuvre en europe
et çà et là provoqué quelques
conséquences désagréables alors quelque
chose que vous pouvez facilement
comprendre c'est que si vous tapez dans
un stade de départ qui deuxième fois
pour toutes
comme le pétrole de ce gros bourg du
clion porte-voix et bien vous êtes
d'accord que vous pouvez pas chaque
année en cours serait plus que l'année
précédente et ça jusqu'à la nuit des
temps d'accord on apprend quelque chose
que vous pouvez facilement comprendre
aussi c'est que vous n'avez même pas le
droit de consommer tous les ans la même
chose
est ce juste
vide étant d'accord même sa maman en
fait quand on est dans ce cas de figure
les mathématiques impose que tout ce que
vous avez le droit de faire c'est de
partir à zéro de capital à zéro est
passé par un maximum d'entre vous
pétrole sont très facile à démontrer le
département savais pas du tout recopier
un tract si vous avez suffisamment loin
dans le temps à l'avenir est entre les
deux passent par un maximum absolu
on a coutume d'appeler le pic alors le
pic de production en ce qui concerne le
pétrole c'est pas une vue de l'esprit
c'est pas un truc de sauzon ecolo cdh un
terrain tomates
soit dit en passant ça vaut également
pour tout ce qui sort des entrailles de
la terre et qui est donnée une fois pour
toutes
donc il y aura également un pic à
l'extraction annuelle de minerai de
clients de minerai de tungstène 2000 rec
de vanadium de minerai de chrome de
diamants désolé mesdames d'or devant
désolé mesdames de platine d'argent de
palladium de rhodium etc prenez
n'importe quoi qui sort de la croûte
terrestre
il y aura un pic à l'extraction elle
même les seuls candidats c'est qu'en
plus tard à quel niveau
et est-ce que c'est grave docteur donc
toujours des données l'armp roulante
pour les diamants c'est un peu moins
grave que quand le pétrole mais mais ce
qui est sûr c'est qu'il y en a un
alors est ce que vous savez pour caen
est le pic de production de tout le
pétrole sur terre qui n'est pas ce qu'on
appelle du pétrole de schiste aux états
unis et ce qui n'est pas des sables
bitumineux du canada
bien il est derrière nous de 10 ans
avait 10 ans qui dépasse donc bien que
padar 3 est dégueulasse avec un
rendement énergétique d'extraction des
très belles et les schistes pied de
pétrole de schiste part donc en fait on
devrait peut-être le brochet est resté
dedans mais il est sous forme diffuse
donc on a besoin de fracturer la roche
pour le faire sortir
c'est également une technique qui est
énergivore par rapport aux techniques
classiques on vous êtes vous perdez
entre 20 et 30% de l'énergie extraite
rien qu'avec le processus d'extraction
alors que les grands puis à terre des
gisements saoudiens vous perdez en tous
sens donc c'est passé depuis dix ans
et alors c'est quelque chose à
surveiller pour l'économie parce qu'il
se trouve qu'on extrait de terre ici
vous avez deux couronnes en rouge vous
avez la variation de la quantité de
pétrole qui sort des roms c'est pas un
prix c'est la quantité le nombre de
tomes et en bleu vous avez la variation
du pib ma personne du pouvoir d'achat 20
personnes en gros sur tout et bien c'est
très exactement le même
donc aujourd'hui cette cour permet de
dire que le premier facteur limitant de
l'économie mondiale c'est la quantité de
pétrole qui sort de terre
tout le reste vous oubliez c'est pas la
peine de s'en occuper ça fait dix ans
que j'ai découvert ça ça fait dix ans
que je suis cette courbe
ça fait dix ans que c'est très
exactement calquer l'un sur l'autre
nonobstant tout ce qu'on a pu se
raconter sur les éoliennes et les
panneaux solaires tout ce qui compte
c'est le pétrole en janvier si je
regarde ce qui sort de terre hors états
unis
voilà ce que ça donne vous voyez que
depuis 2005 ça n'augmente plus donc le
juge de paix aujourd'hui de la
production pétrolière manga qui
s'appelle les états unis s'il en sort
plus chez eux ce qui est 4e moment là
une économie mondiale a des couleurs qui
met
silence ans - l'économie mondiale
souffre entre alors à partir de 2005
nous européens on a commencé à souffrir
vous avez ici la quantité de pétrole qui
rentre en europe
anvers est ce qu'on importe en gros
c'est ce qui vient de chez nous en
incluant la norvège
alors d'abord vous voyez que la verrière
très bon pique pour la mer du nord
c'est la mer du nord très beau big qui
est passé en 2002 bideau bill la
quantité de pétrole qui sort d'un ver
vidor diminue depuis 2009 la quantité de
pétrole qui sont afrique sur l'ensemble
du continent africain anc y compris
l'algérie la libye mais également en
angola nigeria
depuis 2009 le mexique depuis 2005 parce
qu'à sa gueule plein de pays ont passé
leur pic et la russie qui fournit un
tiers du pétrole européen a annoncé il
ya quelques mois dans un article de
presse que ce n'est qu'en 2021 même les
plus anciens dans cette salle non pas
longtemps à attendre pour savoir si
c'est vrai le temps un tiers du pétrole
mondial
donc ce qui s'est passé en 2006 et que à
la suite du plafonnement du pétrole dans
le monde et à la suite du pic de
production du conventionnel et bien
l'approvisionnement européen a commencé
à se casser la gueule vous rappeler deux
contre deux
2008 en 2006 le pétrole baisse
l'économie américaine commence à
décélérer
les prix de l'immobilier se retourne et
patatras présidentielle alors là vous
avez le phénomène chez naïve plus les
prix élevés du pétrole qu'il faut
combattre un peu mieux la mer du nord
qui font reparti à l'approvisionnement
la hausse fin du quinquennat de hollande
avec le chômage qui baisse enfin début
du quinquennat de macron en finlande
avec l'économie qui se porte bien ça va
durer le temps que ça dure pour que le
celle aux états-unis sarah que croître
et ça commence
c'est une autre manière de dire que
notre cher président ans qu'on aime
qu'on les aime pas n'a absolument pas en
main ce qui structure la croissance
économique dans notre pays ce qu'il a en
main c'est la façon de répartir la
croissance son absence sa examen par
contre le fait qu'ils aient la
croissance
c'est pas du luxe dépendant alors on
consomme parc du pétrole en europe en
conserve au sénégal le gaz mais pour
l'essentiel de la mer du nord qui a
aussi passé son pic en 2005 donc
l'approvisionnement gazier de l'europe
qui augmentait d'année régulière
jusqu'en 2005 rien d'une salle krafft
instantanément ça s'arrête d'augmenter
donc tous les gens qui rêvent parce
qu'ils n'aiment pas le nucléaire en
place a dit hier par du gaz prend
complètement convaincu que ça va passer
indépendamment du fait que le gaz serait
du co2 et pas nucléaire mais ma théorie
à moi sommes de toute façon sa masse
parce que si on faisait des trous
partout dans ce pays ce qui n'est pas en
soi voilà à peu près
ce qu'on finirait par sortir manuel et
on n'est pas dans l'exemple de grandeur
quand on pensait ce que nous sommes en
gaz aux pauvres y ont reçu un coup de
chapeau nantes et la ligne en pointillés
vous voyez eh bien vous voyez que depuis
les années 80 la quantité de charbon
qu'on utilise diminue tout simplement
parce que la quantité de charbon
consorts d'évident européenne diminue
l'usta date de bien avant qu'on commence
à se soucier du team art c'est juste que
ça fait dossiers comptables dans deux
mines de charbon en europe donc arrêtée
juste ça et comme le charbon est un coup
d re avec une chaîne logistique est un
cauchemar
c'est à dire qu'il faut des terminaux
portuaires dédié ifo des trains dédiées
etc
la centrale à charbon de leurs actes en
allemagne qui fait 4 gigawatts
électrique
c'est à dire en gros l'équivalent de la
puissance électrique d'une centrale
nucléaire française nous avait trois ans
quatre réacteurs
elle enfourne 50 mille tonnes de charbon
par jour 50 mille tonnes de charbon par
jour
elle crache 6000 tonnes de cendres par
jour dix mille tonnes de sang par jour
passé vous rendez compte donc le charbon
c'est un cauchemar logistique et donc
quand on a moins de charbon qui produit
dans un pays essentiellement on en
consacrant essentiellement est alors
l'europe malgré tout ce qu'elle peut se
raconter sur la transition énergétique
voilà à quoi ressemble sa consommation
énergétique ou plus exactement sa
consommation énergétique par personne
donc ici vous avez la quantité d'énergie
utilisée par personne en moyenne
européenne s'est traduit dans une idée
papa s'appelle des tonnes équivalent
pétrole
peu importe ce qui compte c'est
l'évolution donc vous voyez que jusqu'au
choc pétrolier ça augmente très très
vite
c'est les trente glorieuses dont
certains d'entre vous se souviennent
c'est l'époque où le pouvoir d'achat
augmente très très vite
les objets domestiques augmentent très
très vite on s'équipe en voiture en
s'équipant machine à laver on s'équipe
en afrique
et c'est la consommation augmente très
vite parce que la production augmente
très vite parce que le parc de machines
par personne rend très vite parce que
l'énergie rentrée à partir les chocs
pétroliers syndicats de la quantité
d'énergie disponible par personne
s'arrête deux groupes
en fait la quantité d'énergie de
fossiles disponible par personne décroît
légèrement et ont compensé
essentiellement avec le développement du
programme nucléaire une rente nucléaire
qui fournit aujourd'hui à peu près un
quart de l'électricité européenne
c'est le premier mois de production
électrique dans le nucléaire devant
charbon qui ces gens pour cent vous avez
donc les fossiles divy du mais elles
représentent encore aujourd'hui 80%
parce qu'on utilise encore aujourd'hui
et à partir de 2006 vous voyez que la
quantité d'énergie par personne ce fait
abaisser ce qui concerne l'économie
européenne
ici vous avez la variation du pib par
personne c'est à dire du revenu par
personne en europe sur ces trois
périodes tant qu'on est dans les trente
glorieuses en moyenne et c'est très
élevé 4% par an à l'oubli quand vous
êtes dans les trente ans suivante c'est
les trente piteuses ça des pubs de
consens parents et déjà pour les avoir
acquis il faut que la séance ait déjà
acheté après ses débuts de la pierre à
d'autres de bondy de la dette qui
n'arrêtent pas d'augmenter et après 2006
vous voyez on est quasiment à zéro en
fait jusque si j'avais fait la moyenne
jusque-là à peu près à condé franchement
1 0 est en fait le surplus de croissance
qu'on a ces dernières années
c'est dû au surplus de pétrole de
schiste qui permet d'en apporter un peu
plus il n'empêche que c'est quand même
pas alors si vous êtes prudent où le pib
par personne demande quasiment plus et
que vous faites venir dans l'europe des
gens qui ont un pib par personne très
inférieur à celui des gens déjà en place
ce qui se passe avec la rue l'entrée
dans l'europe des pays de l'est en 2005
qu'est ce qui se passe puisque vous avez
la libre circulation des personnes et
des marchandises
la taille du gâteau de poids augmenter
mais à ce moment les gens qui gagnent le
moins vont aller se mettre dans les pays
où on gagne plus et des industries
des pays où on gagne le plus délocalise
dans les pays où en quelques mois c'est
exactement ce qui s'est passé donc
renault et peugeot délocalise à l'est et
pour les polonais par contre dans un
ensemble où la croissance est là ce qui
s'est passé avec les portugais les
espagnols on peut nous avoir un pib par
personne qui continue d'augmenter
pendant que eux aussi un pib par
personne qui augmente ses parts
impossible qui est en croissance pour
tout le monde
mais si la taille du gâteau n'augmente
plus tout ce que nous avons à voir c'est
au détriment de ce que les autres
doivent abandonner et a cependant qu'on
demande aux anglais s'il trouve ça drôle
et 10 n'ont donc le président c'est déjà
une manifestation de la contraction
énergétique larvée que nous observons en
europe et les tentations en france de
faire pareil et les tentations italienne
de faire pareil etc sont des
manifestations déjà d'une contraction
économique qui s'applique à un ensemble
économique qui n'a pas compris que le
libre-échange partout et tout le temps
au sein d'un continent qui présentait
des fortes disparités qui ne pouvait
plus être rattrapé c'est une mauvaise
idée donc on est au début d'une nouvelle
ère où on se rend compte que mon âme vue
de l'avenir qui n'est pas raccord avec
ce que la physique va nous permettre
d'avoir alors on est attentif aux yeux
là dessus parce que je vous signale que
l'article 3 du traité instaurant l'union
européenne dit que l'union européenne
dise la croissance
c'est la seule constitution répondre à
mandali qui possèdent leur croissance
dans le bas de gamme
parce que ça veut dire que toutes les
politiques européennes sont basés sur ce
présupposé combat regard de la
croissance alors que mon présupposé à
moi c'est qu'on n'aura pas or si vous
n'en avez pas vous chercher à régler
tous nos problèmes y compris la
transition énergétique achevée hier avec
des solutions du pauvre alors que si
vous pensez que vous allez en avoir
vous pouvez vous permettre la solution
mais si vous tentez la solution du riche
vous n'avez pas l'argent où il est sûr
de vous montrer et c'est malheureusement
si on est parti pour faire avec une
partie des choses que nous avons décidé
d'être en groupe alors à côté de ça on a
pas fini avec les petits soucis
nous avons également un sujet sur le
climat alors dans fait on n'a pas de
problème sur le climat puisque vous
savez quel accord de parier que depuis
l'accord de paris ne pas griller fabius
lève son marteau du commissaire priseur
en falloir se prénomme ici vous avez la
quantité de co2 présent dans
l'atmosphère depuis le début des années
cette échelle est gravé en partie par
million volume c'est-à-dire quand vous
avez un litre par milliers de bêtes qui
peuplent
il y avait un bios tél comment j'ai
commencé à m'intéresser aux questions
climatiques on était quelque part par là
donc vous voyez dans début des années 60
on était à 3 120 aujourd'hui on est à
410 ça peut augmenter alors 1995 c'est
l'année où on réunit pour la première
fois les signataires de la convention
climat
c'est donc un grand succès puisque pour
la première fois il ya un accord ratifié
par tous les pays du monde
dix ans on va s'occuper du problème
alors vous voyez le problème avant goût
et pour les mamans
après il ya kyoto qui est une année où
les pays dits développés disent on va
prendre un engagement de lévitation
valeur absolue nos émissions c'est à
dire même s'il ya plus de mon rang même
si l'économie augmentent etc
on s'engage juré craché par terre à ce
que deux émissions baisse les résultats
en 2009 on à copenhague qui est
considéré comme étant un gros échec
si vous regardez bien ce courant on voit
pas tellement
différents simples copains d'accords
d'échec blum et la coop un gros succès
et là on a soi disant paris qui est un
beau succès verra le sens de ce que je
suis en train de vous dire c'est ce
qu'en dit la presse langage que le
journaliste qui a écrit l'article
et bien ça c'est pas parce que c'est
marqué dans le chandail que c'est vrai
ça vous le saviez déjà pour un certain
nombre d'autres sujets c'est vrai aussi
en ce qui concerne cette affaire-là donc
pour le moment
qui d'entre eux doit entendu parler de
greta tout de bergues vient vraiment le
contrat est bien les quatre paires il ya
eu des déclarations un peu féroce mais
que je trouve parfaitement juste elle a
dit c'est pas vrai que ne sont pas assez
parce que si on disait on n'en fait pas
assez ça voudra dire qu au moins on
essaye de faire quelque chose
la vérité c'est qu'on sait rien fait
rien comme la consommation de co2
augmente parce que les émissions
augmentent
si vous avez des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre de l'humanité sur un
siècle et demi à quoi sont dues à la
combustion du charbon à la combustion du
pétrole à la production du gaz à la
déforestation tout ça c'est des
processus qui émettent du co2 le co2 est
un gaz à effet de serre parce qu'ils
absorbent les intéresse c'est ça la
définition de gaz à effet de serre après
vous avez des processus qui émettent du
méthane
alors il y en a qui sont dues aux
agriculteurs dans cette série c'est pas
bien qu'est-ce qui émettent du méthane
c'est à vous avez une exploitation de
combustibles fossiles parce que vous
avez du méthane dans l'élite de charbon
séduisent ou et on quand il des lignes
parce que les vignobles demande des
gentils quand les puits vous en avez
également dans l'exploitation du gaz du
pétrole un peu vous allez dans la
distribution du gaz c'est pour ça qu'un
immeuble sont périodiquement à paris
parce que vous avez des fuites dans le
réseau de gaz
ça fait des émissions de méthane ça fait
probablement plus d'émissions medan que
les fuites au moment de l'extinction
et puis vous en avez également dans
toute la décomposition exactement les
estomacs alors vous voyez depuis que mon
à l'essor des énergies renouvelables
et soit dit en passant les sorts de
l'haïti qui permet de dématérialiser
comment vont évoluer les émissions le
fait que ça ait ralenti le rythme de 11
reste il peut se trouver
je pense que vous en pensez mais il me
semble que si on regarde d'où viennent
nos émissions par activité aujourd'hui
dans le monde d'un qu'est ce qu'on à 20%
des émissions planétaires dia des seules
centrales à charbon vous avez en france
63 gigawatts de puissance installée en
boucle hier que nous excite pour vous
vous avez deux mille 200 gigawatts 200
femmes à charbon dans le monde 60 34 du
clergé de 2200 gigawatts de centrales à
charbon pour te dire les deux degrés
quand vous avez peut-être entendu parler
et auxquels je viendrai dans pas
longtemps
il faut tout l'est m à la ferraille dans
les 30 ans qui viennent car d'ici à ce
que vos enfants et votre âge tout bon à
10% tout ensuite brown opérationnel
vous avez des cimenteries 6 % des
émissions mondiales
parce que faire du ciment s'est cassé du
carbonate de calcium en deux c'est
extraire le co2 du calcaire et ça crache
pas mal de co2 le reste de l'industrie
en émissions directes je parle pas
d'électricité consommée évidemment qui
se retrouvent là en émissions directes
c'est aux 12% est là pour rien que les
aciéries c'est en fait 4 aussi les
showcases au bâtiment dans le monde
c'est 6%
c'est 25 en france mais c'est 6% dans le
monde parce qu'il ya plein d'endroits
n'en souffre pas déjà il ya plein
d'endroits où les autres parlent
camembert sont beaucoup plus rose les
transports ces 14 dans lesquelles vous
avez 6 pour les voitures car pour les
camions et 2 et 2 pour les bateaux et
les avions
l'agriculture c'est 1%
c'est essentiellement des gaz or co2 la
déforestation
ces 10 et là dedans vous avez le
traitement des déchets etc on voit là
d'où viennent les émissions et voilà ce
à quoi il faut s'attaquer si on veut
s'occuper du prêtre climatique vous
constaterez que la dent n'y a pas de
nucléaire
donc si on veut s'attaquer au nucléaire
on peut le faire mais sûrement pas pour
des raisons climatiques et aujourd'hui
dans la politique publique française
il ya eu de confusion entretenue en
permanence en permanence entre la baisse
du duc les airs qui a été décidé au don
d'un accord électoral légitime on pas
n'importe qui portait sur ce sujet
précisément et ce qui concerne le climat
alors on a mis tout ça dans le gros
vocable de transition énergétique est en
fait ya d'autres très distincts ans de
transition énergétique et à la question
du nucléaire et la question du climat
ici de trucs totalement séparées alors
il faut qu'on analyse co2 dans
l'atmosphère le problème c'est qu'il n'a
aucune envie de s'en aller parce que le
co2 est une molécule très stable comme
tous les oxydes c'est une molécule
chimique entre est stable et quand vous
mettez un dock si quelque part
en gros il lui arrive rien d'accord du
mouvement dans l'atmosphère vous n'avez
que deux processus d'épuration du co2
qui est une molécule très stable ou bien
ce co2 se dissout dans l'eau c'est pas
une réaction chimique s'est dit parce
que le côté d'apport
gare ou bien il est repris par une
plante et ça c'est pas non plus une
réaction chimique stricto sensu
c'est une réaction photochimique il faut
de l'énergie pour du soleil un certain
nombre de gens dans cette salle sainte
lucie a pas de soleil s'impose pas eh
bien c'est la raison pour laquelle la
photosynthèse est un processus qui est
endothermique c'est un besoin d'énergie
sinon ça se passe pas et la dissolution
dans l'océan comme la photosynthèse sont
des processus de contact qui n'arrive
qu'en surface à la surface de la terre
dans l'épaisseur de l'atmosphère
ça peut pas se promirent donc le une
fois que vous avez créé un surplus de
co2 dans l'atmosphère
il faut attendre très longtemps pour que
ce surplus s'évacue si demain matin on
arrête les émissions en totalité
on n'arrête pas les émissions et bien ce
que vous lis graphique c'est que qu'au
bout d'un siècle
il ya une petite moitié du surplus qu'on
a déjà créé et qui est toujours là au
bout d'un millier d'années vous avez 20
% qui sont encore là et au bout de dix
mille ans vous avez 10 % qui sont
entendre ce que je suis en train de vous
dire c'est qu'il n'ya aucune de
réversibilité
en ce qui concerne le changement
climatique ok vous ne reverrez jamais le
climat de l'an 2010 ni même celui de
l'an 2018 vous ne le reverrez jamais en
dessous j'habite est la cause de cette
inertie absolument considérable du co2
dans l'atmosphère je peux même vous dire
que quoi qu'on fasse à partir de
maintenant le climat des 20 prochaines
années va continuer à dériver d'une
manière qui est déjà écrite en totalité
quoi que l'on fasse à partir de
maintenant donc la canicule de l'été
dernier savait que le début des
conséquences quoi que l'on fasse de
toute façon quoi qu'en dise
par contre si on commence à s'exciter
sérieusement sur la question
on commence à changer significativement
la manière dont les choses se présentent
pour nos enfants
donc travailler sur la question des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre c'est
travailler pour ses enfants
en gros donc tous ceux dans la salle qui
sont intéressés par les gains à leurs
descendants un patrimoine qui ressemble
à quelque chose devrait être intéressé
par la lutte contre le changement
climatique
parce que c'est très exactement de 50 il
s'agit c'est très exactement 2 55 ça
transforme donc les bacs tampons peu
d'elle et sartre ensemble évidemment les
mandats politiques parce que notre
président actuel sera devenu d'histoire
longtemps longtemps longtemps avant que
cette affaire les filles d'être un
problème pour nous donc ça veut dire
qu'il faut forger des consensus en ce
qui concerne cette affaire là qui
transcende les alternances politiques ça
qu'il faut faire il faut que ce soit par
un sujet que le suivant karine ils
soient d'accord avec le président sur un
peu près préfère aujourd'hui c'est pas
du tout cas par exemple du clae air est
devenue un enjeu de clivage
droite-gauche typiquement n'y a pas
derrière il ya d'autres exemples
c'est typiquement devenu un village
alors qu'on comprend à quel point on est
en train de parler de quelque chose de
massif
je vous propose maintenant de carte du
look d'une aide
randy se dire qu'ils vont vous comparez
les écosystèmes existants
aujourd'hui vous voyez ce qu'il y ait
remercié le mans des forêts et il ya un
bilan au moment d ôter au coeur de la
dernière ère glaciaire vous avez appris
à l'histoire en histoire un qu'il ya de
l'acier interglaciaire de vote avec
l'association et démago des choses dont
il ya évidemment nous sommes dans un
climat beaucoup plus forts évidemment
c'est pas doux qui a monté avec des
filins à ce moment là parce qu'il y
avait bien les hommes qui s'occupent de
change et qu'il a donc le climat change
naturellement toujours changement ce qui
est dangereux en ce moment c'est la
question de la vitesse de la variation
c'est pas le fait qu'il arrive donc un
bilan vous voyez qu'ils aient beaucoup
plus loin alors la première chose qu'ils
n'auraient pas pu y arriver il y avait
un vide ans et qui n'ont rien j'avais
été jumelé avec une commune sud oise
dont l'âge est compris que ce n'était
pas le cas mais non ce n'est pas
possible parce qu'il ya les packs se
doit est évident il n'y avait pas non
plus d'écho c'est ce qui vous
intéressera surtout c'est qu'ils aient
pas de quelle loi
il s'agit donc il y avait pas l'écho
c'est parce que tout ce beau monde était
sous la garde avait pas non plus de
canadiens mais aujourd'hui 220 la
scandinavie était posée sous une haie
d'arbres calotte qui faisait trois
kilomètres d'épaisseur et comme vous
vous en souvenez aussi des glaciers des
alpes descendre jusqu'à 10 ans alors
pour constituer ses énormes cassiers il
a bien fallu prendre l'eau quelque part
le seul endroit où on peut prendre à ses
dossiers dans l'océan il n'a évidemment
pas assez dans l'atmosphère et comme
l'océan est une grande baignoire le
front toujours au même endroit et bien
le niveau de l'eau de l'océan à l'époque
avait baissé de 100 m donc les ferries
transmanche n'aurait pas de problème de
concurrence déloyale avec 48
et pas dans le tunnel a pas de paradis
fiscaux il la manche puisque manche
il fait beaucoup plus sec est beaucoup
plus froid et les écosystèmes installés
en france à cette époque là ressemble
peu ou prou est ce qu'on a aujourd'hui
au nord de la sibérie
alors j'ai passé ici il ya des gens qui
ont essayé cultiver du blé ou du
tournesol dantas verriez que ça pousse
pas très bien donc
à l'époque les écosystèmes européens
étaient considérablement plus des cris
chants et on avait de quoi nourrir dans
l'ensemble du pays
un peu moins que la population du
département sans vie de comptable
d'accord sûr mais totalité de france la
différence de température moyenne qui a
fait passer cette europe le nôtre europe
2,7 et de ce stade là ce stade là quand
on est passé de la halle a à l'évidence
le climat s'est réchauffé et bien
l'élévation de température planétaire
qui a conduit à cette ce réchauffement
est à cette énorme différence de langue
que nous connaissons c'est juste 5
degrés en dividende
c'est juste ça c'est dans 52 m et 1 500
degrés 5 ans 10 ans alors je vais vous
la faire courte mais vonn c'est
absolument évident pour moi que quatre
degrés de hausse ou 5 degrés de hausse
en un siècle
ça ça pousse un pantalon très simple ils
s'appellent ak pardon ça s'appelle la
guerre partout quand il s'agit d'éviter
4 à 5 degrés de réchauffement on n'est
pas en train de se demander si c'est
quelque chose qui est sympathique et riz
à avoir on est juste en train de parler
d' éviter d'avoir à quatre partout une
juste ça quand on est en train de parler
alors à titre personnel je considère que
ça vaut bien le groupe de se priver
quelques ronds points et de la cinquième
c'est pas un avis qui est partagé par
tout le monde est en tout cas c'est bien
le partage comme les nôtres alors dans
les conséquences que va avoir c'est à
ferrari la carte partout où ça va parler
juste parce qu'il a fait un peu plus
chaud
vous allez avoir une planification des
températures mais vous allez aussi avoir
une modification des précipitations est
remarqué que le pourtour du bassin
méditerranéen c'est l'endroit au monde
qui va le plus à sécher dans le cadre du
réchauffement climatique donc ce que
vous avez vécu l'été dernier est ce que
j'ai vécu l'été dernier avec chaud et
sec
malheureusement ça n'est que le prélude
de ce qui va nous arriver de plus en
plus fréquemment à l'avenir ça va
évidemment faire baisser les rendements
agricoles ce qui est un petit problème
avec une population qui est censé
augmenter enfin qu'est censée augmenter
cela pouvait pas boucler le pantin
voilà la proportion a volé qu'on les
forêts françaises en l'an 2000
et voilà à quoi ça ressemble en 2040
donc les landes viendront aussi
inflammable que la formabilité radio
aujourd'hui et vous voyez que la forêt
de la région centre commence à venir
aussi inflammable que les temps
d'aujourd'hui les ouragans vont
s'intensifier ça c'est quelque chose qui
est facile à expliquer avec les mains
mais comme le temps presse
bildt à 2 degrés tous les coraux se
montrent donc c'est un peu ennuyeux pour
les gens qui en vivent
et puis certains mais aussi parce que ça
fait une espèce disparue à partir de 3
degrés vous avez une insécurité
alimentaire généralisée sur la planète
c'est pour ça que leur écart par tous
parce que tant que les gens par bouffer
en général ils sont pas contents le
groenland a commencé à fondre à
l'échelle de quelques siècles
ça va faire trois ans et m dos en plus
pour l'océan mondial et la calotte
arctique de west qui est un vaste
système de glaciers embarque tout temps
les uns sur les autres un peu comme un
château de cartes
ah les glaciers qui sont près des côtes
qui ont commencé à se désagréger et donc
il ya un risque d'effondrement de
l'ensemble de la structure qui est par
ailleurs posé sur un socle rocheux sous
marins etc et des versants donc ça à
l'échelle de quelques siècles
ça pourrait aussi faire 5 hâtive est
d'autant plus dans l'océan mondial 5 à
10 plus 3,6 voilà à quoi ressemblera
peut-être le trait de côte de l'ordre du
nord dans quelques siècles et pour en
arriver là il suffit que l'élévation de
température planétaire des bases les
deux degrés en 2100 ça suffit ce qui
veut dire que c'est pendant longtemps
cette histoire met le doigt sur la
gâchette et d'études voit son visage et
ses mains dans les dernières réticences
t'as pas tout à fait jusqu'à l'an 2020
jusqu'à la fin du xxème siècle les
écosystèmes terrestres avaient une
capacité à reprendre une partie
croissante du co2 que leur art prend de
plus en plus de co2 au fur et à mesure
que la concentration atmosphérique en
co2 augmente elle quand vous mettez plus
de nourriture dans l'atmosphère puisque
le co2 cela ne retire des plantes et les
plantes se portait mieux et absorber ce
surplus de co2 parce qu'elle était
toujours dans des conditions
climatique qui leur permettaient
prospéré depuis l'an 2000
c'est ce qui est illustré par ces deux
graphiques ou là c'est essentiellement
vers et là c'est essentiellement rouge
partout c'est rouge c'est que les
plantes dans le monde ont commencé à
souffrir parce qu'elles sont plus accès
assez d'eau pour pouvoir croître et
prospérer a proportionnellement à la
quantité de co2 question dans
l'atmosphère donc vous voyez que il ya
un nombre croissant d'écosystèmes où ça
commence à souffrir
et comme ça on le voit que en 2018
il va également y avoir un effet sur la
circulation à large échelle dans
l'atlantique nord
donc les conséquences précises à
l'échelle de quelques siècles sont
extrêmement incertaines vous allez avoir
une augmentation de la biodiversité des
agents pathogènes
parce que quand vous chauffer le
bouillon de culture et tout a pas de
petites bêtes qui aime bien ça et vous
êtes en train de constater dès à présent
que ce soit pour les plantes roues pour
les animaux la remontée vers le dehors
d'un certain nombre de pathogènes qu'on
n'avait pas par exemple les champenois
du built your depuis 10 à 15 ans il
avait pas ça c'était quelque chose qui
était plus au sud
la maladie de la langue bleue est
remonté en corse vous avez une
cochonnerie pour les oliviers en ce
moment en italie qui est en fin de
compte etc
vous avez de plus en plus de
cochonneries et on commence à voir en
france le chikungunya dans le retour de
la dengue etc tous ces trucs là vous
remontez vers les pôles
exactement pour des raisons d'efficacité
natif vous avez un certain nombre de
compartiments de stocks de carbone par
d'enquêté immobile depuis très longtemps
qu'ils vont être remis en circulation à
cause du réchauffement et c'est la
dernière phase la plus importante
bien évidemment bien évidemment nous
aurons essentiellement des surprises
vous savez que quand on fait une
expérience pour la première fois en
général
la seule chose dont on est sûr c'est que
peut pas tout prévoir la vente des
mauvaises surprises nous avons
malheureusement c'est comme le pour le
barca j'ai ramené votre enfant à noyer
le mariage cette expérience sera à fait
régulière de thouars le mariage est un
repas qui pense comme elle espère donc
c'est l'expérience qu'on a fait des
milliards de fois et pourtant vous
prenez un couple qui se marie
aujourd'hui vous êtes pas capables de
savoir où et ce pendant 30 ans pourtant
c'est un truc qu'on a fait des bières de
forme donc là c'est évident que concept
d'expérience qu'on fait pour la première
fois nous aurons essentiellement des
surprises et là surprise
les dictionnaires étant bien fait c'est
un truc face auxquels on n'a pas de
capacité d'organisation puisque on a pas
vu le coup venir à lens donc nous allons
de façon croissante être pris au
dépourvu par des choses qu'on n'a pas vu
venir c'est très agréable de venir ça et
plus on démêle puis on a collectivement
alors à ce stade
vous avez donc compris qu'il y avait un
petit sujet à la main et que même si on
se fout du climat on va quand même avoir
un sujet sur pyongyang
donc on est fondé à faire des écoles des
trolls ne serait ce que parce que y
et à laval nous avons un sujet de team a
hélas je vais vous expliquer ce que ça
veut dire les données ici vous avez une
deuxième droite il ya de droite à
souvenirs dans mon exposé il faut se
méfier donnera des deux ment c'est
l'économie c'est une fonction du dr de
l'énergie dans des trucs et il y aura
une deuxième droite dont il faut se
souvenir c'est que le réchauffement
climatique on en 2100 c'est une fonction
linéaire de la quantité totale de co2
complet dans l'atmosphère jusqu'en 2005
c'est très simple vous regardez le
budget total pour de dépenser en carbone
plus qu'en 2005 quantités totales de co2
et ça me garde le réchauffement pour les
lire en une seule année on sent sa
chance pas d'accord juste il faut la
voir alors à fin 2010 8
on a déjà mis dans l'atmosphère un peu
plus de 2200 milliards de tonnes de co2
et donc on a déjà signé pour 1,5 de
lévis autrement si on arrête les
éditions de demain matin et qu'on avait
plus du tout à partir demain matin on
est sûr d'avoir un degré et demi en 2005
donc le 1° et bidons certains d'entre
vous ont peut-être entendu parler dans
l'accord de paris en disant qu'on va
faire du pays un effort pour et ses
façons de faire ce qu'on veut y aurait
derrière c'est un peu comme si quelqu'un
qui a été battu aux élections en 2018 ou
dit je vais faire mes meilleurs efforts
vont faire élire en 2018 si on veut les
deux devaient à ce moment ça c'est
encore la porte et il faut continuer nos
émissions à 3,8 milliards de tonnes donc
2250 ont déjà été émises
donc ça veut dire qu'il en reste 150
d'accord avec moi en parlera des 27 50
ans ce qui veut dire qu'on a encore le
droit d'émettre tiers de ce qu'on a déjà
émis depuis le début de la civilisation
industrielle alors je vais vous le dire
un peu différemment parce que ce qu'on a
et vit depuis le début la civilisation a
essentiellement et débit dans la
deuxième moitié du 20e siècle
ça revient à dire que les émissions qui
ont été le fait des gens qui s'apprête à
mourir dans cette salle 180
doivent être le ciel par trois ou quatre
supérieurs aux émissions auxquelles aura
droit à la génération des bébés qui
naissent aujourd'hui encore génération
des bébés qui naissent aujourd'hui a le
droit qu'au tiers des émissions des gens
dans cette salle qui s'apprête à moyens
alors même que cette génération là il
sera trois fois plus nombreuses et en
pratique ça veut dire que les émissions
doivent être pas derrière doivent être
divisées par trois d'ici à 2050 d'ici à
ce que vos enfants et votre âge
il faut que les émissions planétaires
soit divisé par trois ses cinq domaines
alors maintenant j'en arrive à au seul
truc qui nous intéresse c est ce qu il
nous faut des éoliennes dans cette
histoire alors vous allez facilement
comprendre que ma réponse est donc au
sens de on a tellement de problèmes
beaucoup plus en gardant beaucoup plus
urgents à résoudre que de s'occuper
d'essayer de paix c'est un peu le
nucléaire avec trois éoliennes que c'est
vraiment le top le faire ça en fait pour
moi c'est n'avoir rien compris au
problème qui est tendre c'est quelque
part la meilleure démonstration du fait
que pour le moment rester moyens on est
en train de s'occuper de se gratter un
petit bouton de fièvre à condat sur le
visage à la con à un concours se
menaçant alors pour montrer à quel point
ça va servir à rien cette histoire je
vais vous prendre le cas de l'allemagne
vous allez ici la façon dont va évoluer
depuis 2002 la quantité la puissance
installée en panneaux solaires et une
éolienne en allemagne donc en 2002 vous
voyez l'allemagne avait 10 gigawatts
donc le parti
totale installée en france aujourd'hui
c'est un peu plus de 100 gigawatts un
peu plus de 100 milliards de watts de
puissance électrique installée
toujours pour vous donner un ordre de
grandeur est ce que vous connaissez la
puissance soutirer d'un abonnement
domestique chez vous c'est 6 à 9 kilos
watts si vous jouez à l'électricité sera
plutôt 9
si vous chauffez pas l'électricité ce
sera 6 6 kilowatts ça veut dire que vous
pouvez mettre aussi la pressé dans
l'auto dépendant de ce qu'il aura qui
regardent le pouvait en 29 au même
moment toujours en gros double donc ça
c'est 6000 6 kilowatts 6000 watts
c'est ça que vous avez chez vous et bien
du côté de la production pour l'ensemble
du pays nous avons 100 milliards de vote
sans vie des autres en allemagne donc
ils ont en 2002 évidemment des moyens de
production qui sont ceux qui tombent
donc dé charbon du pétrole et du gaz du
théâtre a qui sont pas représentés sur
cette courbe et puis commence à
construire un parc avec des énergies
renouvelables constitue et éolien et
solaire
à cette époque la cravate qui voyait ça
augmente ça augmente sur ventes est
aujourd'hui ils sont à 100 sans drogue
ça leur a coûté quelques centaines de
milliards d'euros
cinq cents 300 400 ans et envoyés dont
ils ont fortement augmenté le solaire et
l'éolien dans la prison installée dans
toute bonne logique ils ont dû supprimer
des centrales qui produisent l autre
chose
et bien quand on regarde la concession
ils ont exactement la même quantité
aujourd'hui que au début alors c'est pas
exactement les mêmes
oui et qu'ils ont effectivement
supprimer un peu plus clair quand ils
ont arrêté de gaz dans mon client dans
les 100 gigawatts en 2002 il y en a 100
gigawatts
aujourd'hui mais vous pourriez vous me
dire ok ils ont 100 gigawatts de
pilotable j'appelle ça du pilote dams et
là vous pouvez tourner boudon et
d'électricité arrive à la différence de
ses vols là où ça produit quand il ya du
vent et du soleil
donc si vous n'avez que ce mot dollar et
bien d'une conférence ici six éléments
et si a pas de vent et de conférences
donc les horaires de la sncf sont
respectés sourire car si vous me dites
pendant des heures la sncf sont
respectés quoi qu'il arrive vous avez
besoin de boîtes comme sa mère de brad
ou le train à des marathons des boutons
alors vous pourriez vous dire coquine
ils ont leur part que pilotable qui
étaient déjà là ils ont rajouté du parc
dont pilotable en plus les éoliennes et
donc du coup ils ont une production
globalement plus importante
donc c'est juste qu'en fait ils ont
augmenté leur consommation on garde la
consommation allemande et on constate
qu'elle est restée à peu près stable sur
cette période
donc en fait ils n'ont pas augmenté leur
consommation par contre qu'ils ont
augmenté
c'est leur exportation fatal quand il ya
du vent et du soleil donc en gros
contient du vent et du soleil
les allemands sont retrouvés avec trop
d'électricité et à ce moment cette
électricité traverse les frontières a
pris extrêmement faible a pris
extrêmement faible voire parfois plus
négatif et ce qui s'est passé c'est
qu'il avait toujours autant de centrales
mais les centrales
est de l'ordre de 500 perd amateurs 500
milliards de kilowattheures
d'électricité
en 2002 les 130 kg ce qui n'est pas
l'éolienne solaire est aujourd'hui c'est
400 donc ce qui s'est passé en allemagne
ils ont gardé les centrales existantes
ils ont rajouté de l'éolien du solaire
par dessus et au moment où il ya du vent
et du soleil
il baisse la production des centrales
pilotable et au roman vient pas de vent
et pas de soleil loin devant et moins de
soleil
il remonte la production des centrales
pilotable mais ils les ont gardés en
back up
parce que le citoyen allemand a beau
bébé
les éoliennes et les panneaux solaires
idem encore plus que l'électricité pour
faire avancer les craintes un peu tracé
partira ce qui soit dit en passant a en
ce moment en france
j'ai gravi les allemands sont vraiment
pour des tas de trucs que les trains à
l'heure de dire que donc le donc
l'électricité déconsidérés aujourd'hui
le consensus social c'est que
l'électricité est disponible à la
demande
on considère qu'on a de l'électricité
quand on appuie sur un bouton n'est pas
content et du vent et du soleil
ça a toujours été comme ça à l'époque où
il y avait les moulins à vent tombe ou
de levain on gagne avec l'appareil
dentaire et du vent voilà c'est déjà
consensus social et tout le monde était
organisé en conséquence et ont considéré
que c'était normal que ce n'était pas
une injustice si à un moment on compte
céder éventuellement pas de chance mais
c'était pas une injustice quand on n'est
pas le pouvoir politique responsable qui
fait il pas temps aujourd'hui associé
des comptes a bâti est bâti sur un
consensus social qui est électricité
disponibles tout le monde doit chanter
ça on pourrait très bien dire
on accepte c'est simple consensus qu' il
ya des conférences de comté du vent pour
dire mais qu'est ce qui nous empêche
c'est moins confortable que de la faire
même s'il ya pas tant on pourrait très
bien même donc si on fait exactement la
même chose que l'allemagne
c'est à dire d'une développe chez dow
l'éolien et le solaire qu'est ce qui va
se passer on prend pas supprimé
deux réacteurs nucléaires c'est pas mal
on va juste s'en servir - donc quand
c'est du vent et du soleil
on les baisse qui contient pas
convaincantes soleil ont leurs ventes
mais va l'écarter
on va pas du tout comme il est écrit
dans la loi à supprimer un tiers
c'est pas la première fois qu'il ya un
truc qui ne sera pas mal on va pas du
tout en supprimer un tiers
c'est pas vrai par contre on va perdre
sur tous les tableaux le camp des
tableaux sur lequel on va perdre c'est
celui du co2 parce que le nucléaire
c'est g de co2 par kilowattheure
l'éolien à ses 10es de soleil à ses
quarante à cinquante donc un ensemble
éolien du solaire c'est un peu au dessus
de nucléaire
donc si je best duc les airs en
production annuelle en puissance
installée pour remplacer par véolia du
solaire se gâte rien sauf co2 je perds
même un peu le deuxième tableau sur
lequel je perds c'est l'emploi à dire
comment ça va pouvoir au moins il ya de
l'emploi dans les filières renouvelables
où il y en a les filières renouvelables
mais c'est comme l'avènement de la
grande distribution vous rappeler les
hypermarchés 17h dans l'hypermarché ya
d'emploi à temps les parents chez
certains par contre la quantité de
petits commerces détruits à côté il faut
faire un bilan mais tu es bien en ce qui
concerne des renouvelables c'est
exactement pareil pourquoi parce que
quand vous faites un mégawatt heure avec
du nucléaire vous importez le radiant
n'y a pas de big d'uranium en france
mais pour faire un mégawatt heure c'est
à dire un millier les kilowattheures du
dr vous avez besoin d'importer un euro
du rack'am pour faire un pilier de
l'innovateur avec de l'éolien du solaire
vous avez besoin d'importer 20 à 40
euros de composants parce que nous ne
fabriquons pas les panneaux en france et
nous ne fabriquons pas les éoliennes en
france
les dix premiers fabricants de panneaux
bond sont tous chinois
il n'y a pas plus mondialisé qui est pas
de saccades accord avec le solaire
l'énergie et l'eau calme ça c'est
parfaitement vrai elle est renouvelable
c'est parfaitement rêve par contre le
dispositif de collecte c'est à dire le
panneau des dix renouvelables 10 locales
et pour les éoliennes c'est exactement
pareil
ben les allemands aujourd'hui ont
délocalisé leur vie
fabrication en chine une bonne partie
des usines de siemens
aujourd'hui ils sont en chine donc si on
passe d'une et du nucléaire sur l'éolien
le solaire ce qu'on fait c'est qu'on
augmente les importations introduction
constante et là quand vous augmentez les
importations à production constante à
macro économie de base nous permet de
dire que vous détruisez d'emplois vous
détruisez un emploi par cinquante mille
euros d'importation supplémentaires
c'est très simple donc vous en créer
dans les filières renouvelables ne vous
en détruisent et plus encore à
l'extérieur et enfin la troisième chose
sur lequel vous allez perdre c'est le
risque des clés est d'ailleurs comment
ça va moins d'électricité nucléaire
parce qu'on peut augmenter le risque est
hyper bien sûr ici parce qu'à partir du
moment où vous garder le même nombre de
réacteurs
parce que aucun d'entre vous dans cette
salle même favorables aux éoliennes et
ses enfants quelques vins et bien vous
n'accepterez pas pour autant que le
train de 8 heures parc à dover et du
soir trente huit heures du matin bart a
d'ailleurs été du soir pas ce n'est pas
tant le matin vous n'accepterez pas
arrivée à l'hôpital et que l'hôpital ne
nous soit ne veux pas parce que vous
n'accepterez pas que vos gamins by par
l'école parce qu'à plateforme et il
n'accepterait pas que la magasin souvent
en rupture de stock
parce qu'il n'y a pas de formes vous
n'accepterez pas ça même s'il est contre
le nucléaire donc ce qui va se passer
c'est qu'on va garder les centrales et
on va les garder parce que il vous faut
l'électricité tout le temps mais ils
vont moins produire puisque quand il ya
du vent et du soleil
on est les membres ont dit qu on les
baisse un peu comme elles produisent
moins elles vont moins gagné d'argent
or une centrale elle vous d'exactement
la même chose qu'elles produisent ou
qu'elles produisent pas d'accord donc si
vous gagnez moins d'argent mais que vous
avez toujours les mêmes charges en face
de deux choses l'une où vous entretenez
moins bien votre centrale des risques
dus claireaux pente où vous allez à la
barre du tribunal
ça s'appelle faire faillite et en ce
moment le contribuable est obligé de
remettre la main à la poche parce que il
prônera toujours pas de pas se faire
soigner à l'hôpital et qui est pas
courant les jours maintenant
donc nous allons perdre de l'emploi
augmenter le risque nucléaire
et n'ont rien gagné sur le co2 et ça
nous a déjà coûté à fin 2010 8 mai sans
maquillage à fin 2010 8 la totalité de
l'argent qui est déjà allé qu'il ira au
producteur d'électricité éolienne et
servir en france 120 milliards dont 120
j'ai eu un rendez vous il ya un an et
demi avec le directeur de cabinet
adjoint de bruno le maire
je lui ai demandé savez vous en fait ces
mêmes indics sont le tutoyer jeu super
bizarre
sais tu combien est-ce que le pays a
déjà engagé une fin 2018 dans l'éolien
le solaire c'est juste pas 7 milliards
d'euros
le numéro deux du cabinet à bercy c'est
vous dire
donc hier on ne se réalise pas les gens
de risques alors je vais vous donner ce
que je vous donne quelques exemples ce
qu'on aurait pu faire avec 120 milliards
d'euros
est ce qu'il ya dans cette salle les
gens qui sont chauffées au fioul alors
c'est pas bien en oubliant il ya 4
millions de ménages dans ce pays qui
sont chauffées au fioul
4 millions il ya une solution de
remplacement pollution qui s'appelle la
pompe à chaleur 5 août quand c'est bien
seul et pompage à leur atout ménage
français chauffées au fioul
tous ménages français chauffées au fioul
ça me coûtait rien de 40 milliards
d'euros il m'en restait encore 80 pour
faire autre chose donc qu'est-ce qu'on
aurait économisé avec ses 40 milliards
d'euros on n'aurait pas à économiser
quelques milliards d'euros
d'importations par an du coup on en a
créé 100 à 200 vies d'emplois dans
l'économie française avec ses les
éditions avec ses importations éviter et
nous aurions évité 10% du co2 émis par
le pays
d'accord donc on aurait gagné trois
années de trajectoire vers un monde à
dos 2 avec 40 les 90 après qu'on reste
encore 80 qu'est-ce que je peux faire
avec 80 se posent les villes de train
n'ont pas d'argent je fais des libres 2
un jeu l'isolent de l'idole des
logements sociaux jeux de service
continu d'accord donc avec cet argent
j'aurais pu acheter un vélo électrique à
tout le monde enfin voila je vais au
électrique à chaque français jr express
avec mes 80 milliards d'euros donc je
vous voyez ces gens que j'aurais pu
faire des choses qui auraient évité
considérablement plus légaux doggy sur
les combustibles fossiles
ça aurait été bon sur tous les tableaux
bon sur les importations donc sur
l'emploi
bon sur nos émissions de co2 dont
éventuellement sur ma santé
parce que s'ils remplacent les
chaudières à fuel par des pompes à
chaleur j'évite les émissions de so2 les
particules fines et cetera des sauniers
ratio sans contrainte chaudière à fuel
j'aurais pu faire plein de trucs qui
aura été extrêmement utiles dans la
course contre la montre que je vous ai
décrites et là la gaspiller notre argent
pour quelque chose qui est de l'or pour
moi du programme de charlotte donc je
vais finir par là en fait si j'en avais
pouvoir et je dis pas juste ça vous fait
plaisir je dis ça parce que c'est très
exactement ce que je pense
demain matin à marseille attendait on va
vous coller des obligations sur la tête
quand même ne pas les mêmes les
obligations qui vont vous donner c'est
il est interdit de remplacer sa
chaudière à fuel par d'autres opérations
mais les gens n'ont pas les moyens on
les aide
c'est autre chose vous avez l'obligation
d'isoler votre enfant vous avez 30 ou 40
ans pour sa chance en ce qui concerne
l'agriculture il ya énormément de choses
à faire qu'il a aussi demandé de
l'argent il faut remettre de la valeur
ajoutée dans les exploitations faire
plus de transformation en maîtres de
leur pouvoir avec tf faire plus de
polyculture et ajax et 40 ans de boulot
à faire développer tout un tas de
pratiques qui aujourd'hui sont encore à
compulser hante
il ya plein de trucs à fait à main de
domaines qui sont parfois des choses qui
vous demandez un peu de contraintes
quand même ça va demander un peu
gourmand organisé mais la guerre de
choix dont on ait besoin chez vous c'est
ça alors je vais finir avec le charisme
pagnol ici vous avez le cas espagnol
vous voyez que en même temps qu'ils ont
installé le 25 gigawatts dont 25
milliards de watts d'éolien ils ont
installé 25 gigawatts de gaz
parce que les espagnols comme les
français entendent avoir de
l'électricité quand il prend le condamne
pour autant une large partie des
français pensent que l'éolien et le
solaire ça fait partie de la
décarbonation de l'économie oui 80% des
français très exactement vers ici c'est
que 80 % des français pensent que le
nucléaire contribue un peu beaucoup aux
émissions de co2 80 %
peut-être que dans cette série n'a pas
beaucoup mais 80% alors il ya deux trois
raisons que le voit cela la première
c'est que l'image d'epinal de la
centrale nucléaire c'est ton pull donc
peut-être que les gens se disent voilà
une peau qui fument donc c'était à
contribuer au réchauffement
la deuxième chose c'est que les articles
le répète en boucle fossiles et
nucléaires d'accord on assimile toujours
les deux actrices on m'assimile des deux
c1 doit avoir les mêmes inconvénients
et comme la transition énergétique
consiste à se débarrasser des
combustibles fossiles et abc de
nucléaire
probablement aucune partie des gens se
dit un peu vite en tout ça c'est que
s'attaquer aux mêmes problèmes dans le
secteur nucléaire pour faire partie du
problème et c'est particulièrement vrai
quand la population
on sera joli et se féminise ce qui est
un peu ennuyeux pour moi parce qu'il se
trouve que par ailleurs la catégorie de
la population qui est la plus sensible à
l'environnement ces femmes et ces jeunes
donc c'est un peu ennuyeux pour moi que
la catégorie de la population qui la
plus sensible à l'environnement soit
aussi celle qui est l'idée la plus
fausse
en ce qui concerne le nucléaire parce
que ça veut dire que c'est ça qui va le
buste aussi à la route pour qu'on
s'occupe d'un faux problème plutôt que
de s'occuper des vrais problèmes
si on met le nucléaire du côté des
solutions eh bien vous voyez que la part
des énergies décarbonées en france est
très supérieur à ce qu'elle est en
allemagne
alors si on veut vraiment jouer à ce jeu
là qu'est ce que ça va deux côtés vous
avez ici un petit calcul que je me suis
amusé à faire je vais prendre un système
si caricaturale dans les cas de figure
mais c'est pour un peu toucher les
coeurs demandeur j'imagine un système
dans lequel on n'a que des éoliennes et
du stockage qui est un système dans
lequel on
des réacteurs nucléaires soit dit en
passant avec des réacteurs nucléaires
aujourd'hui on sait faire le suivi du
chant français d'accord alors que du
côté éolien le facteur de charge
annuelle
une éolienne c'est plutôt un peu
ressentir qu'à la fin de l'année elle a
produit comme si elle avait tourné vers
son but en aplat depuis 168 23
ça veut dire que la production identique
vous allez devoir installer 3,4 plus de
puissance
handéo lien indiqué m après la durée de
vie d'une centrale nucléaire s'est donné
pour 60 en fait tous les américains vont
passer leurs centrales existantes à 60
et ils sont déjà en train de discuter
pour 80 or et l'hôpital de pontivy
fonctionne et donc vous allez devoir
stocker et ça ça va vous rajouter 50 à
60% par rapport au coût du système alors
que du côté des aires de stockage en a
pas beaucoup
vous avez quelques stations de comptage
donc là vous allez augmenter d'un
facteur 2 à 4 le couple ensemble
par contre le co kg a installé six ans
entre deschamps et donc là vous allez
avoir une division par 2 à 4 du coup qui
l'aurait installé en face vous faites x
3 x 2 x 25 x 2 que davis de été retrouvé
grâce à l'arrivée avec un goût de
l'ensemble du système qui va être en
gros d'un ordre de grandeur aux est en
défaut dit voilà c'est une autre manière
de dire que de remplacer un système tout
nucléaire par un système tout
renouvelable
c'est très exactement ce que nous sommes
en train de faire en ce moment avec la
tentative que nous avons de remplacer
une partie du nucléaire part de l'éolien
du solaire
on est très exactement en train de faire
ça on est en train de s'occuper des
raclures sur le gouvernail
malheureusement on va payer
[Applaudissements]
le sans plus tarder on va passer aux
questions
il ya des micros baladeurs quel sens ce
qu'ils veulent c'est lancé mais il ya
une image que j'ai pas encore eu le
temps de mettre dans ma présentation
c'est dommage parce qu'elle est
aujourd'hui
il ya quelqu'un qui a fait une
représentation virtuelle de ce que
représente la totalité des déchets qu'on
a déjà produit en france souvent d'un
gros cul posé sur le port de marseille
est en fait vous rendez compte que c'est
pas quand je vous la totalité des
déchets qui ont déjà été produits par le
parc nucléaire en france ça occupe le
kart de cet espace dans lequel nous
sommes ici donc c'est des trucs qui sont
dangereux et c'est des tout petits
par ailleurs il faut savoir qu'au bout
de quelques siècles
l'essentiel de la radioactivité cdg a
disparu parce que des déchets qui sont
ici l'essentiel de la radioactivité a
disparu parce que les déchets très
radioactifs sont par ailleurs des
déchets qui durent pas très longtemps et
autrement si ça crache beaucoup ça veut
dire que ça va pas cracher très très
longtemps
inversement les trucs qui durent
longtemps sont des trucs qui crachent
pas énormément les geôles audi alors je
vais parler un petit peu chif
la quantité de déchets de haute activité
et à l'obscurité qui ont fait chaque
année en france
c'est à lyon va dire 2 g par français et
6 pièces de monnaies par français la
quantité de déchets industriels fait par
personne en france c'est 300 kilos là
dedans vous en avez sans qu'ils sont
considérés comme des déchets toxiques et
100 kg de déchets industriels
les déchets nucléaires de grands donc
voyez c'est des cochonneries mais c'est
des cochonneries qui sont ne change
absolument pas le tableau de je viens de
vous brosser et c'est renoncer au
nucléaire au motif que ça fait des
déchets malheureusement toutes les
alternatives en font encore plus vous
faut par exemple une fois plus d espace
pour faire la même quantité
d'électricité avec du solaire qu'avec du
p r 1000 fois plus d'espèces il vous
faut 100 fois plus de [ __ ] pour faire
un kilowattheure solaire que confère un
kilowatt heure nucléaire
cent fois plus de cuivre s'est il vous
faut c'est encore plus de ciment
fabrique donc vous avez des multiples
qui sont absolument astronomiques
donc si vous voulez pas que co2 le débat
c'est entre nucléaire les barrages et
éolien en gros et de poids et vous avez
des lipides partout donc dans le
nucléaire vous en avez dans le fait
qu'il faut s'en tenir un premier en
piste ans
c'est des choses que l'on sait faire
aujourd'hui dans le bois à la limite
c'est fait un rapport tout le monde
parce qu'il ya une concurrence sur le
sol dans les barrages d'aller vite c'est
le fait qu'il faut des montagnes et en
france vous avez à peu près on va pas
tout équipés aujourd'hui il reste pas
grand chose d'équitable sur les
montagnes et dans l'éolien et le solaire
la limite c'est que vous avez besoin de
considérablement plus de beto donc de
considérablement plus de livres qui font
aussi des tas de déchets toxiques soit
dit en passant que ce dont vous avez
besoin pour le nucléaire donc à chaque
fois vous avez les inconvénients et il
faut choisir ceux qui tout bien pesé et
représente les plus facilement gérable
pour l'humanité dans son ensemble
toujours en ce qui concerne vous savez
qu'en france il ya vous parlais tout à
l'heure au co2 il ya plus de gens
voulaient pas montré il ya plus de gens
qui ont peur des déchets
r que des gens qui ont peur des
accidents domestiques est ce que vous
savez combien de morts par an en france
en accidents domestiques marie bigard
s'est excusé quand il ya des gens plus
peur des déchets nucléaires et des
piscines
parce que vous savez combien de morts
par an font les dc3 semble donc
énormément des deux jeunes enfants
je connais pas un bébé qui dort avec des
qualités aujourd'hui
donc vous avez aujourd'hui donne 2 il ya
quelque chose qui est depuis pavlovien
dans les déchets du prg en design et en
fait quand vous regardez la réalité de
ce que c'est c'est dangereux mais
gérable parce que c'est des petites
quantités et je vais finir par lever les
notes historiques
vous avez au gabon en ligne au radium à
droite vélodrome où vous avez une
centrale nucléaire qui a fonctionné
naturellement il ya deux milliards
d'années
alors ces viandes naturellement parce
qu'à l'époque la teneur en uranium 235
dans l'uranium naturel étaient plus
élevés qu'aujourd'hui
depuis ça a disparu par radioactivité
est donc on s'en va qui a fonctionné et
donc l effet des déchets exactement
comme les pommes ce qu'on fait
aujourd'hui une proposition
exactement comme aujourd'hui eh bien
allez descendre ses déchets personne ne
les a gérées évidemment gardé par la
police
donc ils ont été blessés j'ai envie de
dire la hausse et des personnes il vient
il se trouve que ces déchets leur
descendance
évidemment les déchire en spa où ils
sont transformés les ventes d'armes et
bien les descendants sont là les des
gemmes ou déformée donc en 2 milliards
d'années ça va changer de place donc si
on va faire un trou en deux sets en
passant
si on va faire un tour dans la meuse
pour y mettre les déchets qui est
aujourd'hui sont en surface à coup
d'état donc sont plutôt moins bien
défendu un à 400 m sous terre puisque
vous assurer que le père de famille que
je suis est inquiet pour tout ce que je
vous ai raconté l'état pour ça je suis
très inquiet avec ce que je vais
raconter un gars comme ça des conneries
mais c'est quand même pas très rassurant
dans un tableau là les déchets
nucléaires c'est vraiment pas un motif
de commencer par s'occuper du nucléaire
donc surtout quand on voit que je
voulais dire car les éoliennes ça ne
baisse pas paritaire
en mai les chèques qu'ils sont
et enfin je le sais dire vas me faire
rire dans cette salle aujourd'hui on
fait dans quelques centaines de tonnes
de déchets nucléaires très emmerdant par
an en france on bazarde dans les
chambres des dizaines de milliers de
tonnes de phytosanitaires non mais voilà
donc cesser sa maquette du stade
voilà donc les déchets nucléaires
ce que j'ai envie que c'est pas de la
provocation ce que je viens de dire a
lancé je pense que qu'aujourd'hui ça
fait partie des voies de fait et on a
d'autres qui sont beaucoup plus sombres
présentation qui partage partage tout à
fait les éléments et je trouve très
pédagogique mais je voudrais rester sur
quelque chose de positif
est ce que vous vous intégrer dans votre
schéma historique le fait qu'on pourrait
être aussi sur un cycle de réchauffement
climatique et que voilà est-ce que c'est
à l'intégrer dans le schéma et d'autre
part un autre élément positif
est ce que vous avez des informations
sur la recherche par rapport à
l'absorption du carbone est ce qu'on
peut avoir quand même des antidotes à
ramasser ces gaz à effet de serre alors
je n'ai pas raison d'être positif
malheureusement pas sont les deux
questions déposées en ce qui concerne le
réchauffement climatique il faut savoir
que ces bases scientifiques il ya plus
d'un siècle
l'effet de serre a été identifié par
fourier
on va célébrer dans quatre ans le
bicentenaire de la découverte de l'effet
de serre pas fourni sa date de 1824 les
gaz à effet de serre ont été identifiés
tous dans la première moitié du 19e
siècle fois dont la moitié du xixème le
réchauffement qui suit un doublement du
co2 dans l'air elle qui correctement
calculé par un radius en 1897
donc les fondamentaux scientifiques sont
anciens et on sait aujourd'hui de ses
biens l'effet de serre qui provoquent le
réchauffement à cause de plein
d'éléments d'observation je vous en
donner un si c'était le soleil qui
devait provoquer le réchauffement
on devrait logiquement observé un
réchauffement plus important lahouari du
soleil que là on en arrive pas donc la
température devrait monter plus vite aux
tropiques qu'aux pôles et elle devrait
monter plus vite
l'été que claire c'est très exactement
l'inversé qu'on est en train d'observer
en ce moment très exactement l'inversé
qu'on est en train d'observer en ce
moment
la température au plus vite au pôle
d'autres en pick donc ça ne peut pas
être le soleil par contre c'est très
cohérent avec un réchauffement avec la
structure spatiale d'un réchauffement
attendu quand c'est l'effet de serre qui
augmente parce que quand vous
intercepter les infrarouges terrestre
plus la température de départ est basse
et plus la belle quantité d'énergie
intercepté aux élèves la température de
façon importante la loi du rayonnement
de corps noir en physique ils permettent
bien le dossier deuxièmement une partie
du rayonnement solaire c'est des ultra
violets s'est arrêtée par la couche
d'ozone dans la haute atmosphère
si l'intensité du rayonnement solaire
aux pentes on nous envoie donc plus
d'ultraviolets donc la couche d'ozone
intercepte plus d'ultraviolets donc la
haute atmosphère pour se réchauffer la
stratosphère de se réchauffer au resto
qu'aujourd'hui on observe une
stratosphère se refroidit et ça c'est
aussi très cohérent avec un
réchauffement qui vient d'un surplus
l'effet de serre parce que l'excès de
fer intercepte le rayonnement près du
sérieux et du coup empêche le
rayonnement des restes de réchauffer la
stratosphère et vous avez plein d'autres
éléments de cette nature donc à bord du
giec aujourd'hui la partie scientifique
ça fait 2000 pages c'est bien qu'on ne
peut pas expliquer les choses en trois
et donc il ya strictement pas le moindre
doute sur le fait que ce qui est en
train d'être mis en route en ce moment
ces liens dû aux activités humaines
il n'y a pas le moindre doute là dessus
le surcoût de co2 dans l'atmosphère
ces deux tracés isotopique mans on sait
que ça vient des combustibles fossiles
je viens d oeil sur tous les sentiments
malheureusement donc ce n'est pas dû à
un phénomène naturel c'est dû à nous en
ce qui concerne la séquestration du co2
parce que c'était ça la question alors
les mots des poètes
la bonne nouvelle c'est qu'on a
très efficace pons axa ou plus
exactement les plantes donc là vous avez
30 élèves vous avez deux manières de
reprendre du co2 de l'atmosphère
c'est changer les pratiques agricoles
par exemple les pratiques sont à vous
c'est quelque chose qui permet de
remettre du carbone dans le sol par
exemple l'augmentation de la biomasse
aérienne avec des aides comme ça ça
permet d'augmenter le groupe du carbone
et par exemple le fait d'avoir une
question forestière plus dynamique
ça permet également d'augmenter le
contenu carbone en particulier si vous
faites à partir du bois des produits
durables
donc si au lieu d'utiliser voix pour
chauffage pour le chauffage vous
utilisez des pompes à chaleur
comprenez le bois pour remettre dans les
maisons sous forme de produits figurent
deux siècles et bien à ce moment vous
avez retiré le carbone de l'atmosphère
mais comme je voulais monter tout à
l'heure
le problème c'est qu'avec le changement
des conditions climatiques
malheureusement une partie des plantes
vont arrêter de jouer ce rôle depuis
qu'on aimerait les voir jouer pour
retirer du co2 de l'atmosphère vous
allez plutôt un processus qui va avoir
tendance à s'emballer
est-ce qu'on peut le faire
technologiquement cette affaire là et
bien la réponse elle est à tout prix et
au bout d une fois que co2 dans
l'atmosphère
il est présent sous une concentration
qui est de 0 et 2 0 4%
l'ubo les qualités chimiquement inerte
présente à 0 et 0 4% wallon la retient
que jamais d'un concert seules les armes
ça me faire ça parce qu'ils savent
exploiter l'énergie du soleil pour le du
soleil par an pour le faire on est des
gens vont bien imaginer des feuilles
artificielle j'ai pas quoi et c'est
l'énergie de fabrication baffles
crachent plus de co2 que ce que la
faille
mais de récupérer par contre ce que vous
pouvez imaginer ce faire il ya des gens
qui n'imagine faire ça sans empêcher co2
d'aller dans l'atmosphère on a des sens
concentré que c'est aux deux centrales à
charbon et des centrales à gaz etc
c'est un processus qui s'appelle la
capture et séquestration alors ce
processus fonctionne il ya des
démonstrateurs c'est très bien le vert
simplement c'est un processus qui
consomment de l'énergie pour fonctionner
et il consomme de l'ordre de 20 à 30 %
d'énergie de la centrale alors de là
vous avez deux options ou bien la
centrale produit 20 à 30 % d'électricité
en moins et à ce moment il faut répartir
les économies d'électricité donc le vrai
problème est à la balle n'est pas dans
la centrale il est comment est-ce que
france les gens à faire 30 % d'économie
d'électricité derrière ou bienvenue dans
y'a pas de raisons je vais je vais
produire autant d'électricité à ce
moment il faut en cours des 40 concerts
charme en plus mais quand vous êtes déjà
à 50 mille tonnes de charbon par jour
comment est ce que vous en ferez 40% de
charbon en plus basse et pas
nécessairement facile
donc vous avez et il faut casser les
trucs dans la centrale pour remonter la
taille des brûlures mettre des colonnes
pour verser appelé les abîmes qui
captent le co2 et donc il ya des gens
qui pensent qu'on va réussir en enfer
quelques-uns l'idée que ça devienne une
clé majeure pour valeur pour éviter de
mettre du co2 dans l'atmosphère dans les
50 ans qui viennent
personnellement j'ai quelques doutes
donc autant faire très bien en faire à
gagner je préfère de très loin quand
même de l'argent maintenant contre les
éoliennes mais ça va quand même pas être
un élément majeur du changement si je
vais directement à la fin de cette
question c'est qu'est ce qu'il faut
faire
en ce qui concerne le co2
malheureusement oui il faut démonter les
métropoles
il vaut acheter moins de trucs de toute
nature il faut accepter de vivre dans un
peu moins d'espacé habitable
il faut accepter d'avoir une activité
qui est plus près de chez soi il faut
accepter que les objets on en achètera
pas souvent et qu'on ait réparé a du
coup ça va ralentir la diffusion du
progrès parce que la diffusion du
progrès c'est justement des objets qu'on
change souvent parce qu'à chaque fois
ils sont bio que ceux qui ont précédé et
c'est le plein de trucs donc c'est un
renoncement quelque part à de la
conservation matériel en échange du fait
que l'horizon se dégage en ce qui
concerne la confiance en l'avenir
c'est simplement ce que ça le deal
quelque part qu'on doit faire
si on a envie de s'occuper seul de
prendre ce problème et on doit le faire
mondialement
alors comme il ya pas de chef mondial il
faut commencer je suis bien chez nous à
les concevoir merci de votre exposé chez
deux questions parce que je les
comprends que vous étiez un post it is
si déchets bien compris personne ne
pense à personne parfaite mais pas de
félicitations
donc je lui ai posé deux questions
pourquoi pas la géothermie et deuxième
question pourquoi pas travailler sur le
stockage de cette énergie tout
simplement
alors le stockage de l'électricité ou
l'énergie le fond cela vous avez pu
montrer que c'était l'énergie au sens
large
alors l'énergie fossile années déjà
stocké armatures
c'est ce qui la rend si intéressant le
bois déjà stocké par nature et soit dit
en passant l'hydroélectricité déjà
stockées
dur aussi où stocker le stocker
l'électricité
c'est quelque chose qui est très
difficile âpre au jour d'hui le payeur
dispositifs de stockage de l'électricité
dans les réseaux électriques c'est les
barrages réversible on appelle des
stations de pompage
on en a quelques unes en france mais on
se parle pas beaucoup d'énergie dedans
parce qu'en fait il faut stocker
beaucoup d'eau pour faire un peu
d'électricité
on pourrait très bien imaginer de faire
mes doutes et vallées des alpes et de
recouper toujours du lait ben voilà mais
quand vous faites ce genre de calcul ça
rentre dans mon facteur fin là quand on
passe du nucléaire à l'éolien que je
vous ai évoqué tout à l'heure et en plus
vous avez quelques barrages de 6 grâce
dans la sphère peut-être compagnie crs
qui font envoyé spécial quelques
personnes qui vont mettre d'accord ce
que j'aime à dire mais qu'on voit dans
mes coups j'ai pas mis des crs et des
halles et simplement d'élite chiffre est
beaucoup trop bas ce qui concerne le
stockage de l'électricité historiquement
si ça monte aujourd'hui à grosjean qui
place les espoirs dans les batteries
il se trouve que le stockage de
l'électricité dans une patrie c'est un
stockage électrochimique qui se faire et
du métal en fait une partie d'une des
tables c'est la raison pour laquelle
tous ceux d'entre vous qui ont travaillé
une batterie standard on va dire pour un
site de voitures autre acteur il avait
vu s'imposer grâce et nous sommes tout
simplement parce qu'une batterie scib et
al et qu'est ce qu'on fait dans une
batterie ou lyonnaise des atomes de
métal plus l'énergie que vous stockez
elle est en gros à peu près la même quel
que soit le poids de la tonne de métal
d'accord donc si vous me lisez un atome
de club vous gagnez pas grand chose par
rapport à égaliser
de lithium il se trouve que le lithium
c'est le métal le plus léger contretemps
dispose sur terre c'est pour ça que
c'est les batteries au lithium qui vous
permettent d'avoir la plus grande
attention et l'énergie stockée par le
côté droit ça va stocker quelques
centaines de watts heure par kilo qui en
dira pas considérablement au delà
tout simplement parce que la physique ou
la termine et quand vous commencez à
regarder la quantité de lithium qu'on a
sur terre la quantité du site qu'il
faudrait faire la quantité et cetera
la quantité d'électricité qu'on conserve
aujourd'hui vous vous rendez compte que
vos enfants seront voir donc ce jour
parlent donc c'est beaucoup plus simple
d'avoir un dispositif d'électricité
pilotable j'en reviens à mon cher
nucléaire plutôt que de s'emmerder la
vie à avoir un truc pas pilotable
derrière lequel on mettait les batailles
la raison pour laquelle vous avez tant
de gens qui poussent aux batteries et
aux dispositifs pas piloter cette fois
c'est que à partir comment vous avez
besoin
comme je les montre et là dans le monde
une des conclusions que vous pouvez
tirer de ce calcul c'est aussi avoir un
système éolien plus stockage travaux
coûtent 20 fois plus d'investissements
qu'un système nucléaire
la bonne nouvelle c'est que ça fait
travailler 20 fois plus des fournisseurs
d'équipements donc c'est la raison pour
laquelle tous les industriels que je
connais sont très très favorables à
l'idée qu'on colle des éoliennes partout
et des batteries partout parce que ça va
leur faire beaucoup plus de boulot doro
dans le monde des électriciens des
fournisseurs de matériel électrique des
gens qui font des spas regret lesparre
pilule et les smart chose ils sont tous
à fond sur les élèves elle des éoliennes
interchangeables et l'électricité
intermittente et stockage parce que ça
fait des volumes d'activité beaucoup
plus importants pour avoir la même
quantité d'électricité rarement ceux qui
sont historiquement tendues que les airs
sont pas d'accord tous les autres ils
sont d'accord à cause de ça parce que ça
leur fait beaucoup plus de beaucoup plus
en plus donc stocker l'électricité en
masse si je donne des ordres de grandeur
aujourd'hui la consommation
d'électricité mondiale ces vingt-trois
mille milliards de kilowattheures par an
un critère l'auteur un cathéter l'auteur
la capacité totale de stockage sur
batterie qu'on doit avoir dans le monde
d'aujourd'hui doit un peu dépassé 1
térawattheures dans 23 villes parents
aux enfants sont morts guillaume savoure
donc on va en faire un peu mais ça va
changer
la deuxième question c'est la géothermie
alors en fait la géothermie la pompe à
chaleur que j'évoque tout à l'heure
c'est à géothermie si la géothermie
parce qu'en fera-t-il ans a un très gros
potentiel mois dans les choses que je
préconise qu'on fasse en france c'est de
remplacer tout chauffage au gaz
viol par sa éventuellement avec un
chauffage au bois en appoint pour que
les quelques jours un peu froid dans
l'année où c'est compliqué de tirer sur
la pompe à chaleur parce que décroche à
ce moment vous avez un poêle à bois vous
permet d'avoir chaud les trois jours par
an mais si donc c'est ça que je pense
pertinent complet géothermie basse
température un énorme potentiel
la géothermie haute température qu'on
vers l'électricité avance avec nos pairs
de lenche faut être près d'une faille où
vous avez de la chaleur près de la
surface
vous avez en circuit ouvert parce que
vous faites circuler l'eau dans le
sous-sol ce à prix ouvert auquel ce
charme tota pas de saloperies corps
dante qui quand elle remonte vont nous
bouffer vos équipements donc ça veut
dire qu'il faut avoir des trucs très dur
si donc ça vaut cher donc vous avez
quelques mois dans le monde vont dans
les squats aux philippines en islande et
c'est à l'essai militer à quelques
endroits dans le monde ça à part un
potentiel énorme dans le monde dans son
ensemble pour faire de l'électricité bas
carbone dans le monde le rôle potentiel
pour faire d'électricité les deux gros
potentiel pour faire d'électricité bas
carbone les barrages bruguière mais les
barrages c'est pas d'armes je rappelle
que le barrage des trois gorges a
déplacé six fois plus de banques que
l'accident de tchernobyl
cent cinquante mille personnes dans un
cas un million en doute le plus grand
lac de la raho monde fait cinq
kilomètres carrés un département
français notamment noyer c'est un
barrage en afrique et en amérique du sud
mais quand vous avez vous avez donc la
géothermie pour pour finir deux sur ce
sujet là pour le chauffage c'est une
excellente idée
merci monsieur jancovici d'être venu je
vous ai suivi beaucoup de fois sur son
interview sur présage donc les éléments
de constats poudre et c'est je pense qu
ici on n'a certainement pas partagé
notamment cette question aussi des pics
en termes de matières qui vont pas
forcément de vous permettre de
construire un vitam aeternam les
convertissent à moi même question quand
même sur les éléments de constats il y
en a une c'est qu'on parle et vous êtes
là où aujourd'hui pour parler de
changement climatique mais dans la
foulée du changement climatique par
l'effondrement de la biodiversité et
j'aimerais bien en termes de comparaison
par rapport à la rue l'urgence les deux
phénomènes sont liés mais bon je suis
agriculteur bio donc j'aurai juste ou
parasites ça en interne de degré
d'urgence de l'un par rapport à l'autre
et finalement vous savez pas pouvoir
faire quelque chose comme ça après moi
c'était plutôt deux choses que vous
abordez vous ces dans la question
à ces constats c'est qu'est ce qu'on met
en oeuvre une action je dis pas comme
solution c'est en marchant qu'on apprend
à marcher
il ya une chose qui n'a pas été abordé
ici fin dit comme ça dans vos
interventions vous parlez souvent devenu
clair en termes d' amortisseur des
décroissances donc on est bien dans la
perspective comment on fait donc je vous
en parlais un peu reprend c'est un petit
peu mais pas spécifiquement
et après ça nous concerne tout cela
autant que moi je suis dans
l'indre-et-loire plutôt du côté de
richelieu chaînon donc deux communautés
connus qui sont dotées d'un plan climat
air énergie transition qui permettent de
faire atterrir vos constats sur les
territoires et du coup que nous en tant
que citoyens c'est à dire préoccupé par
ça qu'on puisse s'en emparer et comment
engager dessus sur mes deux communautés
de communes parce qu'elles ont eu les
mêmes ces deux communautés de communes
ou mal pour shi lang à la centrale chez
lieu il ya des chants ont clairement
fait savoir en dehors du fait que la
disent pas ce qu'est une problématique
transport qui est la première source
derrière c'est le chauffage parce qu'ils
sont nombreux du patrimoine tout le
monde
patrimoine mais le corps est fière de ça
c'est que c'est beaucoup de surface
habitable du temps chauffées au fioul
voilà et ça c'est s'est pas démenti
mollement il ya des bureaux d'études qui
les font intérêts sur les territoires
donc je voudrais pas que ça c'est la
première chose et la deuxième sur notre
secteur 6
l'aviculture donc quand vous avez dit
que aujourd'hui à 120 milliards joue
l'europe c'est allé vite là dessus
qu'ils sont dépensés par l'état
française sur l'état pour le contraire
c'est nous parle encore plus quand c'est
comme ça et la décision c'est pas nous
moi j'aurais bien que du coup avoir un
pouvoir de décision donc je pense que
déjà le pca l'été c'est un pouvoir de
décision aux gens qu'à chacun ici dans
ledit neige pas comment ça se passe mais
on a un projet d'éolien qu'est-ce que
sur des bois donc du coup moins 10 la
meilleure alternative c'est alléchant le
câble de discuter avec les gens qui vont
s'occuper de la transition a consacré le
pct nous intéresse énormément et donc je
suis un peu long mais bon c'est cette
question des 120 milliards vous avez
parlé de comment vous les réutilise riez
est ce que vous pourriez vous aussi des
des sources
parce que vous êtes pouvoir détailler
mais quand on sentit si on pourra
regarder sur ce documentaire on est au
vélo on pourra voir ça dans le tablet ça
nous aiderait sur les territoires parce
que moi j'ai envie de sortir ici de
faire quelque chose alors il ya eu
beaucoup de questions sur les pouvoirs
de la biodiversité c'est aussi un vrai
problème
aujourd'hui en fait on est à l'heure des
choix c'est à dire que ce qui s'est
passé
une expression que j'utilise parfois
dans les interventions c'est à dire que
l'on a vécu la première partie du pacte
faustien et la partie du pacte faustien
c'est super sympa on a vendu son âme au
diable mais on sait pas encore
enfin complètement il n'est pas encore
passé la collecter mais on est avec
marguerite tout se passe bien et
maintenant on est enfin sorti tiens on
est en train de sortir de cette époque
bénie où on n'avait que les avantages et
les inconvénients
on commence à être rattrapé par le
rebond des gangs et on est vraiment à
l'heure des choix
et comme disait le poète choisir c'est
renoncer donc la première chose dont on
a besoin c'est d'un débat buts sur les
choix qu'on fait on aura battre donc à
quelqu'un c'est qu'est-ce qu'on veut y
abondent
est ce que par exemple collectivement on
est prêt à avancer à saint gilles et ça
nous fait déjà quelques milliards sont
libérés et qu'on peut l'utiliser autre
chose oui ou non moi j'y suis tout à
fait prêt à regarder du porno en haute
définition est déjà bien assez rock de
fiction enfermés pour assembler dans
l'aéroportuaire définition vous marier
la vidéo en ligne c'est 80% la bande
passante internet netflix youtube et le
porno c'est 60% et 80% pardon oui voilà
pourquoi je vous dis on peut s'appeler
80 grammes à l'époque de canal+ camps
s'étaient brouillés il peut être un peu
flou
le vrai choix de voir que sa première
chose dont on a besoin avant même
quelque part de dire faut faire ce qu'il
faut faire ça c'est de se mettre
collectivement en position de comprendre
qu'on n'aura pas tout à la fois et
qu'est ce qu'on choisit d'avoir et à
quoi on accepte de rose la lune vacances
et qu'il accord là-dessus tout de suite
ça va beaucoup mieux
alors moi dans les choses qui sont du
côté auquel j'ai pas envie de renoncer
il ya effectivement la préservation de
la biodiversité parce que on en dépend
derrière ici pour ça je dois payer
beaucoup plus cher
si l'accord
ça fait maintenant 15 ans que j'achète
un producteur j'ai la chance d'avoir au
marché un producteur bio
donc j'y vais je sais qu'en volumes
aujourd'hui ça ne suffit pas pour que
tous qu'on puisse faire pareil et j'ai
la chance de l'avoir soit dit en passant
ce n'est pas plus cher qu'au supermarché
parce que j'arrête a comparé les prix
je vois bien et je vois là mais je sais
qu'en faisant ça je fais ce que je peux
faire de mieux pour la biodiversité ça
et en environnement les chats des
voisins qui vous fait en étant donc donc
je mange moins de viande parce que je
sais très bien qu augmenter la quantité
de viande qu'on mange c'est une pression
sur les surfaces qui se fait au
détriment aussi d'appeler diversité ou
une pression sont les rendements qui se
fait au détriment de la biodiversité
donc la saraï faut demander aux gens
parce que oui ou non vous êtes d'accord
pour que la préservation de la
biodiversité se paye une fête que vous
allez payer votre nourriture plus cher
oui ou non
sinon ce n'est pas de mise en garde et
avec la baisse de la biodiversité
si oui aux 5es à ce moment la question
mais qu'est ce qu'on fait est réglé
lefebvre ont balisé mais on sera pas
tout en même temps
donc la première chose à faire en fait
c'est la première question qu'est ce
qu'on fait c'est encore une fois qu'on
s'est dit qu'est ce qu'on peut faire à
ce moment vient le temps de l'action
mais moi je faisais qui par exemple je
préfère qu'on s'occupe du co2 plutôt
qu'on s'occupe du nucléaire c'est pour
ça que 120 milliards je préfère le
mettre dans des pompes à chaleur et des
vélos et des pistes cyclables etc plutôt
que on met ça dans les éoliennes c'est
ma préférence avant tout le monde n'a
pas nécessairement la même donc je leur
ai dit il faut qu on est d'abord une
préférence collective sur la façon de
faire latter versa dans les territoires
alors là aussi petite réflexion
d'abord la chose que je ne serai pas à
cette parisien vous expliquer la vie
mais par contre ce que je sais c'est que
les méthodes sont partout pareils
almeida comme appareil comme achille ont
d'ailleurs c'est à dire qu'il faut
segmenter entre ce qui est à notre main
sans avoir besoin de demander l'avis de
personne
ceux qui vivaient à votre main qu'à
condition vous mettiez d'accord à
plusieurs en faire un usage public et ce
qui n'est à votre vin qu'à condition que
tout le monde est au bout donc en fait
il faut regarder à quel échelon vous
avez besoin de taper pour faire croire
si vous avez juste besoin d'une place de
marché pour aller vendre la production
d'un agriculteur bio supplémentaires
il n'y a pas besoin d'aller emmerder
l'elysée pour ça d'accord c'est un truc
qui est totalement locales et c'est un
petit bout du chemin si vous avez
localement quelqu'un qui est prêt à
financer une action donnée quelle qu'en
soit la raison
vous n'avez pas besoin d'aller taper
ailleurs et vous avez la possibilité de
le faire chez vous si vous avez
quelqu'un qui est suffisamment riche
pour ne pas avoir besoin d'une aide pour
remplacer sa fédération par une pompe à
chaleur l'avouer tout simplement lui
demander de faire rage au cap
il n'y a pas de trucs qui peuvent être
faits à l'échelle locale sans engagement
après vous avez besoin d large à
l'échelle à chaque fois que vous avez
besoin de dakar un plus larges pouvoirs
à chercher en typiquement la
réglementation y en a eu d'autres partis
qui est d'ordre national voire européen
dont changer ça à l'échelle locale c'est
compliqué mais levi démocratie sont des
systèmes en même temps il faut bien que
sa part que quelque part les gens disent
ben moi je préférais
90 quand ils sont suffisamment nombreux
à dire ne pas faire exception prenant de
fait ça finit par se passer autrement
c'est long c'est le problème est belle
donc ce que j'ai envie de vous dire est
plus simple et plus une game de tri et à
votre action que de vous faire un
inventaire à la prévert de tous les
trucs qui s'emballe un versus ces trucs
qui sont pas mal à la seule chose que je
peux vous dire est qu'il irait part ça
c'est que s'occuper du problème et
d'autres que je viens d'évoquer ses
adeptes le relever comme un choix
éthique
dit autrement ça ne peut pas relever les
rationalités économique
il y a aucune espèce de rationalité
économique derrière le fait de vouloir
préserver le climat
si vous voulez essayer de justifier
savoir des chiffons tant que vous voulez
de façon dont les amendes seront
toujours foireux pour une raison très
simple c'est comme les ressources
naturelles sont gratuites par convention
d'un système économique le système kiva
tickets gratuits par convention donc une
fonction dommages sur un truc est
gratuit par convention il faut sauver
l'honneur en fait vos viandes
donc ça doit relever que d'un choix
éthique donc et un choix éthique en
démocratie ne peut relever que de la
volonté majorité donc c'est pour ça que
je le disais la partie débat essentiel
les pas des barbares discuter à l'infini
le débat de le structurer tout d'abord
on comprend pas la batterie tu es une
femme accomplie pour les battre et d on
essaye de se mettre d'accord sur ce
qu'on accepte qu'on accepte pas comme ça
qu'on avance donc la pédagogie problème
est aussi importante le passage à
l'action
parce que sans démagogie du problème
l'envi de passer à l'action de façon un
peu large existe pas et c'est pour ça
que le petit personnel je passe autant
de temps à essayer de faire la pédagogie
des problèmes parce que je crois que
c'est vraiment la racine de tous
messieurs bonsoir déjà joué et merci
pour l'initiative fait renverser pour
l'exposer à un danger venu en tant que
voisin je suis à 20 km et je suis
directeur d'un objet qui produit 5 %
d'électricité française sans émettre de
co2 la centrale nucléaire de chinon et
est du coup ma question était justement
sur l'éducation parce que je connaissais
les études d'opinion nous avait montré
et finalement comment on arrive à
ramener les gens dans cette rationalité
après avoir dû débat la première
question qui était sur les déchets
nucléaires étaient intéressantes parce
que l'on peut rentrer dans un vrai débat
avantages inconvénients mais la question
de ranger nucléaires dans des émetteurs
de co2 comment on arrive comment on
arrive à faire cette pédagogie comme en
arriver à expliquer ça il ya plein de
niveaux auxquels il faut le problème
auquel se heurtent ses consorts de 15
ans de l'étoile coûts et dans le sens
inverse un jeu
une des raisons que j'y vois pas la
seule vous allez peut-être trop et a
tiré par les cheveux mais quand même je
regarde c'est la fable howard est
effectivement qu'est ce que ça vient
faire dans cette histoire
la fable ou rtf ces deux moments en
groupe vous avez des médias qui
deviennent privée tf1
ht par an et une partie des médias qui
reste t-il de service public alors avant
lui le dr c'était très simple
journaliste fermer sa gueule
ils étaient des dizaines de houthis un
canton après arrivent les médias de
services privés où les journalistes sont
libres de dire ce qu'ils valent un os qu
à ce moment les journalistes se disent
nous on a notre liberté de parole et
dans le service public
ils commencent à revendiquer exactement
la même liberté de parole et quelle est
la meilleure preuve
ce pique nique vous allez leur liberté
de parole sinon que dire du mal de tout
ce que vers public et donc vous
retrouver aujourd'hui avec les médias de
service public qui sont les plus anti
chose publique de tous les médias
français sur france inter que vous allez
trouver des gens qui cassent des flics
caisses du juge test des politiques et
casse de nucléaire et 15 de la sncf tout
ça écrit dans les parcs et ça fait 10 55
dur donc une fois que l'on vous a répété
en boucle pendant quinze ans que c'était
un truc cac à berck
et bien tout le monde s'il dit
paramètres convaincu donc sur la bbc
vous avez des reportages qui vous
montrent que tchernobyl a été transformé
en réserve sauvage et que la
biodiversité est revenu à ce qui se
passait avant que les hommes d'affaires
des activités agricoles dans points nous
auraient jamais un truc comme ça en
france le film c'est comme ça vos liens
avec donc ça veut dire que vous êtes
obligés d'avoir une voie de
contournement des médias sinon c'est
compliqué alors j'avais suggéré à des
dirigeants d'eads est en effet plus un
froid j'avais eu d'effet donc quelqu'un
qui serait sur le fond parfaitement
d'accord avec vous à savoir la trabi
lewandowski
je leur ai suggéré un certain nombre de
fois de mettre 3 millions dans une
société savante qui ferait simplement de
la pédagogie de la falaise qu'il s'agit
pas de dire c'est bien c'est mal il
s'agit juste de dire voilà ce que c'est
juste vous expliquer voilà ce que c'est
et quand il ya des gens dans le monde
scientifique qui ont un avis sur les
causes que ça produit les conséquences
que sarah et cetera je vous en parle
exactement comme le giec vous parle de
ce que vous avez dans le monde des
physiciens et des chimistes et des
biologistes sur ce qu'on sait sur le
changement climatique
exactement de la même manière ça n'a
jamais été suivies d'effet alors je
trouve qu'aujourd'hui la maison dans
laquelle vous êtes des camps être prise
un peu entre deux feux
puisque ça fait également quinze ans que
le nucléaire dans ce pays et est pris en
est pris au milieu des agressions et à
la petite semaine
donc ça fait quinze ans que vous avez un
actionnaire qui passe son temps à dire
que nous fait de la merde tout en disant
que le faire donc au bout d'un moment ça
finit par devenir un peu compliqué et ce
qui est en train de nous arriver à
flamanville pour moi certes il ya eu
perte d'expérience en france mais pas
que
c'est aussi un système qui s'est
sclérosé par ce que il est pris dans les
injonctions contradictoires en
permanence pour faire cette pédagogie
est absolument essentiel ça sera le ça
sera quand ça sera difficile
malheureusement il ya pas tellement ya
pas des trucs qui peuvent faire un peu
changer la changer la donne attendez les
premiers black out en allemagne petit
changement qui s'entend dans l'opinion
vous avez une fois quand pas dans
l'ombre et il n'y a pas de débat de
solutions garde
j'ai même envie de dire tu sais pas si
c'est vrai mais je vais bien entendu
dire que les syndicats enseignants
étaient contre l'enseignement de la
radioactivité au collège et au lycée
parce que dans les syndicats
d'enseignants les matières littéraires
se représenter c'est l'ancien selamat
petite minorité des enseignants et les
autres étant massivement anti nucléaire
il envisageait donc on a aujourd'hui
presque j'avais qu'il n'y ait que des
bases en chine est originaire c'est
compliqué il ya également une faille du
politique dans cette histoire parce que
à partir du moment où le nucléaire ou le
politique surf sur des peurs
irraisonnées
il est quand même assez vous parle on
n'est quand même pas très loin de la
chasse aux sorcières s'il avait couru et
éthiques
dans la façon d'exercer leur métier il
ya un truc qui devrait faire c'est faire
en sorte que les gens est une idée du
problème à traiter qui sont encore à
quai c'est à dire que l'aixois non plus
très poussée et j'ai pas de solution
miracle au problème si vous le temps
rires des sciences
je suis là alors j'ai un accent qui est
pas dit si c'est que nous nous trouvons
confrontés aujourd'hui nous sommes
devenus des otages d'une politique à
court terme qu'elle soit de gauche ou de
droite
j'avais bien conscience c'est à dire une
politique de celui qui crie le plus fort
ce qu'il faut faire
alors une fois il faut acheter des
voitures utilisent pour la planète
ensuite les voitures qui utilisent
quelques instants ils sont montrés du
doigt en fin du mois les propriétaires
parce que ce soit on est destructeur à
la planète
ensuite il faut rouler à l'électrique
parce que c'est super bien
sauf que l'électrique c'est du nucléaire
et le nucléaire c'est très mal donne
ensuite voilà il faut maintenant faire
du verre tout est vert on voyait même
votre capital employé partout tout est
bien tout est vert tout est merveilleux
et lorsque vous vous levez le matin que
son poignet devant chez vous comme ça
nous est tous ici pas de mesures qui
s'élève dans la campagne puisque j'ai la
chance de vivre dans
campagne que j'ai choisi parce que
justement je l'aimé parce que séoul a
des charmes de la terre c'est ce que
j'aime juillet loin de la terre et que
vous voyez un jour un mât de mesure qui
s'élève vous téléphoner à la mairie et
puis on vous dit n'allez pas pourquoi
qu'est ce que c'est on a ça se fait à
vue d'écouter les mâts de mesure ça
pousse pas comme du maïs parce que voilà
ici alors dans les mains de balma is
épouse carla se met à tout cela mais pas
de mesure est ici d'amener ça pousse
comme je veux dire l'humaniste pas alors
c'est un petit peu bizarre finalement
ont fini par me dire que quand même ses
voiles carrière alors mon rôle taillé et
on nous invite à une réunion
d'information qui nous prouve par x
mensonge que l'éolienne général pas
d'assez plein la société va être sauvée
voilà moi je suis arrivé ici en 1984 le
jeune avait rien j'avais j'ai vécu même
darleux dans le camping lou souleï de 12
heures au début puis par dans le travail
celui de mon mari ni ben voilà on a fait
on a acheté une maison pour la
transformer
fort de cette expérience
en vérité il ya deux ans donc c'est
voilà c'est une histoire de tout le
monde ici chacun a sa petite maison
chacun a sa petite fille et voila j 110
sites français s'il vous plaît
je suis pour et mahmoud israël et là
c'est à dire que on est en train de
mettre des éoliennes partout dans le
monde des armes en montrant du doigt en
disant que si on refuse les remises
accordées pour le nucléaire et ne venez
pas des mots en français parce que mon
français aujourd'hui doit consommer
mieux doit rouler avec une voiture
électrique et vote accepté les unités de
méthanisation et les éoliennes à côté de
chez lui et moi je dis non
sauf que bat la politique le
gouvernement a transformé le décret et
on n'arrive pas à lutter contre ces
promoteurs qui partait baux
emphytéotiques je dirais honte et font
signer aux agriculteurs des papiers dont
ils ne savent à ne pas cautionner et qui
font rêver aussi les communautés de
communes et des maires en leur disant
qu'ils vont recevoir beaucoup d'argent
voilà
j'ai pas grand chose ça parce que ce
n'est pas une question ça rebondit en
fait sur ce qui a été évoqué juste avant
par le directeur c'est exactement la
même chose c'est à dire qu'en fait vous
regrettez que on vous impose une
nuisance pour une mauvaise
c'est exactement ça alors comment est-ce
que ça peut remonter
malheureusement alors si je vais quand
même vous faire un tout petit cours de
politique c'est parce que vous avez lu
les mémoires de michel rocard ton
expérience sur son capot 4.2 ghz
rocard a eu cette formule qui est restée
célèbre 2006 il a dit premier ministre
c'est un métier dans lequel vous
prendrai toutes les deux minutes une
décision sur un dossier que je les paye
ton regarder et c'est effectivement à
peu près ça ce qui veut dire que une
fois que les gens sont en fonction ils
ont plus une minute pour apprendre et ça
veut dire qu'à ce moment là la seule
chose qui compte c'est d'arbitrer des
rapports de france dont qu'ils ont des
conseillers techniques mais qui en fait
sont pas des gens qui sont
nécessairement techniquement compétente
c'est des gens qui connaissaient avant
et qui lui font confiance
en fait ils fonctionnent toujours de la
même manière quand ils arrivent au
gouvernement parce qu'un gouvernement
politique le cas de l'acteur et chose
d'étrange comprenait des gens en qui
vous avez confiance vous fichent de
savoir s'ils sont compétents
techniquement au point qu'ils verront
bien donc vous prenez des gens qui vous
avez confiance
et en fait le temps qu'ils apprennent
laisser passer devant l'être un peu
probable ce qui veut dire que les gens
du gouvernement ils ne savent faire
qu'une chose en pratique c'est triste
mais c'est ça c'est ça avec du jeu donc
il faut comprendre extrait avec cinq ans
jouent ils arbitrent les rapports de
force tant qu'ils pensent il ya plus
d'électeurs a gagné parce qu'il a sur le
nucléaire que dans ma a gagné parce
qu'il tape sur l'éolien tapant son le
nucléaire c'est stupide
c'est dramatique au regard de ce que je
vous ai évoqué ces criminels c'est comme
ça que ça se passe
ce qui veut dire que si vous ne pouvez
jouer qu'avec cette règle
malheureusement donc ça veut dire mais
c'est un peu ce qui est en train de se
passer
la fédération grande colère là c'est
exactement ça c'est à dire que c'est les
gens qui va être jouée québec du jeu
utilise part ça on n'a pas envie donc on
va être moins suffisamment gros montrer
suffisamment mais d'en faire
suffisamment de procès jusqu'au moment
où enfin si l'on se met à réfléchir
il ya un truc qu'il faut absolument
mobilisés dans cette affaire-là sally
bigham tant qu on en revient à la même
chose qu'eux donc à chaque fois que vous
avez quelque chose qui peut passer dans
un journal typiquement un problème aux
parents le sujet complète à leurs
enfants
le sujet de la démantèlement qui se
retrouve à la charge de l'agriculteur à
cause de la structure duale
s'il y en a trois qui se retrouvent
terriblement garder avec un truc comme
ça s'est passé à côté d'un journal si
vous retrouvez il faut occuper l'espace
il n'y a pas tellement d'autres manières
de faire dans le système politique et
d'autres qui s'appelle à berlin les
ministres insistent là-dessus parce que
c'est dramatique mais c'est comme ça les
ministres ne passe pas les décisions
qu'ils prennent sur des argumentations
rationnelles permettant de dire partant
d'une bonne compréhension des faits
c'est exceptionnel qui fonctionne comme
ça c'est triste c'est exceptionnel c'est
exceptionnel qui fonctionne et par
ailleurs on a maintenant 20 ou 30 ans 2
en fait depuis la fin des trente
glorieuses c'est dans la fin de la
période facile où on pouvait demander au
corps techniques de faire quelque chose
toutes façons ils avaient les moyens
physiques de le faire depuis la fin de
cette époque là on se retrouve dans une
crise de confiance entre le monde
politique et la technostructure et le
monde politique n'accepte pas de la
technostructure lui mettre des limites à
son action en disant ça on va parler ça
et c est donc depuis maintenant vingt ou
trente ans le monde politique passe en
temps à décerveler l'administration
c'est exactement ça qu'on fait dans
l'énergie et à ce moment les gens qui
sont dans que deux ou trois options
il doit y est vous j'en connais qui sont
intrigants psychanalytique jeu quand
vous avez félix ont rudement derrière de
viol et d'eric de 3
ils deviennent ce qui se ferait donc il
a fixé rapidement l'instruction
ministérielle en sachant très bien
qu'ils sont en pleine convalescence
fiscalisation à laurent riche carrière
pour cela les meilleurs bars en premier
et ensuite les deux autres choisissent
en train de devenir schizophrène et et
devenir le 14 mai mais c'est triste
j'ai fait une intervention la semaine
dernière devant l'assemblée du corps des
mines et une un décor post it be et je
le redis il est vraiment plu aux gens de
réinstaller le devoir de désobéissance
fonctionnaires
il est urgent que quand quelqu'un qui
est vraiment imprégnés du service de la
collectivité pendant ce temps son âme et
conscience qu'on va voir le travail qui
disent non moi je veux convaincre alors
que le oui vous avez clairement vous
avez clairement montré décisions
urgentes à prendre et que la démocratie
telle qu'elle existe aujourd'hui la
meilleure façon d'arriver à ces
résultats
commissariat pour le climat vous
travaillez sur ces sujets vous essayer
de travailler sur comment faire épauler
peut-être de constitution pose pas
encore il faut dire qu'on est une sorte
que onze on vient juste de démarrer
c'est les emplois gratuit à temps
partiel donc cdc je vais être paie
contrats doivent terminer mon pays non
mais en fait ça parce que ça nous plaît
évidemment le populo conseil pour le
climat pour ceux d'entre vous qui sont
pas au courant c'est un organe un peu
plus ce qui a été créé c'est dans ce
pays quand on sait pas préférant
précarité donc à de plus qui a été créée
par macro en novembre dernier au moment
où on discutait de la préparation comme
il y avait le dr donc c'est aujourd'hui
grosse personne mais on va passer à 13
enfin lancer des idées pour savoir qui
est qui sera aidé à l'est d'ankara où
des 11 et le mandat qui nous a été donné
c'est d'avoir un avis sur la trajectoire
française en matière d'émissions de gaz
à effet de serre c'est sympa d'avoir un
gars comme ça hop se faire gronder 14
personnes de s'auto censure au sein de
donc dit autrement ont délimité par de
conviction si on n'arrive pas à se
mettre d'accord pour dire un truc on
dira pas mais c'est juste parce qu'on
n'est pas d'accord
personne d'entre nous d acheter là
dedans vous avez des gens qui sont
chercheurs
la présidente qu'elle franco canadienne
et elle est basée en grande bretagne
les chercheurs de l'université anglaise
donc à marca puristes
donc on est absolument sûr il ne sera
pas achetée par l'état français et ont
dit exactement ce qu'on veut donc le
premier rapport qu'on a rendu en juin
dernier ils portaient sur la cohérence
de l'action publique est en vie d'avant
et en fait la principale conclusion
qu'on a fournis c'est qu'aujourd'hui
l'état ne se donnent pas les 20 qui ne
se donnent même pas les moyens
d'instruire les conflits l'objectif que
nous avons entre les différentes choses
que nous cherchons par exemple on a un
conflit d'objectif évident entre la
croissance et d'environnement on un
scrutin aujourd'hui on pense qu'on peut
avoir les deux îles à vous entendre on a
des conflits d'objectifs entre
l'environnement et le plein d'autres
trucs
et aujourd'hui on a pas d'endroit où on
se dit qu'on ne peut pas avoir la foi ça
et ça qu'est ce qu'on choisit on en a
pas donc c'est sale ça c'est quand qu'on
a mis dans notre premier rapport c'est
que on avait aujourd'hui les pas
d'objectif incohérent et ne se donnait
pas les moyens d'essayer de les rendre
cohérent ce qui veut dire qu'on soit
capable un seul profit d'objectifs
louables aux exemples du conte monde il
faut faire baisser les émissions de gaz
à effet de serre de la france mais on va
pas le construire un quatrième terminal
a grossi est-ce que c'est très facile de
faire baisser les émissions du transport
aérien selon commence par ajouter un
terminal je suis complètement convaincu
que ce sera le cas je vous donne un
deuxième exemple l'île de france
aujourd'hui est capable de nous fournir
6% son alimentation
vous avez à gonesse excellente et
rabelais qui sont laissés là pour le
restant de la course 1 parmi les
meilleurs en france qu'est ce qu'on va
faire on va les bétonner en faire un
centre commercial
enfin je suis pas sûr que ce vaccin
parce que mon avis
c'est qu'au descendre ce truc est donc
le nouveau nul à l'université n'importe
qu'elle fédère c'est évident
qu'aujourd'hui on le fait en conflit
avec des tas de trucs on a dit qu'on
ferait sur l'environnement y compris
d'éviter l'étalement urbain est un truc
qui améliore guettant vie par le
gouvernement donc le temps les choses
qu'on a fait au conseil c'est de dire ça
c'est de dire aujourd'hui on cherche
même pas à se donner une cohérence
d'ensemble
on cherche même pas donc on cherche je
vais pas parler avoue pascal cultes
comme j'ai essayé de faire ce soir je
suis désolé rabatteurs de qu'est-ce
qu'on choisit la recherche d'épaves
derrière on va voir sur de coin d'en
parler à la pratique personnelle moi
j'ai très envie qu'on reste sur des
sujets je n'ai pas tellement beau qu'on
appelle de gouvernance c'est-à-dire la
façon de prendre les décisions plutôt de
faire un inventaire qui répétera pour la
15e fois les trucs qui sont pertinents à
faire si on veut s'occuper du pilat
parce que manifestement s'il n'a pas
encore fait c'est qu'on n'arrive pas à
cette décision
donc ça renvoie à la question vous allez
poser qu'est ce qu'on doit modifier dans
le fonctionnement de la démocratie il ya
d'argent pour des tas d'idées
par exemple il ya des gens qui pensent
que les représentants de vannes tirés au
sort
personnellement je trouve que c'est
plutôt une bonne idée parce que je vois
pas comment ça peut plus mal fonctionné
avec la démagogie qui bien des élections
et je vois pas comment ça pourrait
concéder plus mal je vous invite à lire
alors les références mais sur le fond à
la valeur en raison d une interview de
claire nouvian qui vient de paraître
dans le nouvel obs où elle explique
pourquoi il abandonne la politique
malheureusement elle résulte un peu gâté
hervé sur les fonds seraient 10 est
ainsi proche de quelque chose que moi je
dirais en des termes un peu plus policé
qui est que dans le monde politique
ceux qui sont le plus en lumière ces les
plus incapable parce que vous voulez pas
faire deux choses en même temps qu'un
bon politique qui est de prendre le
pouvoir et cachez vos dossiers peut pas
faire deux choses en même temps si vous
voulez prendre le pouvoir vous pouvez le
plateau de télé en permanence et donc à
l'intérieur c'est re alors vous pourriez
être cru à l'intérieur et vous appuyez
sur des jambes qui sont compétentes mais
malheureusement ce n'est pas ce qui ce
passe temps pleurer je sais que ce n'est
pas là mais j'aimerais bien faire parce
que c'est important
donc c'est donc au concert
on souhaite à moi c'est qu'on continue
d'avancer sur des recommandations qu'on
pourrait faire pour changer la façon
dont on prend les décisions
parce que tant qu'on n'a pas fait ça je
pense qu'on va tourner en ou en tout cas
on va qu'on risque de tourner en rond
pendant beaucoup trop longtemps pour
être capable de prédire une crise parce
que la faim qui se voir ces acridiens
alors la crise au sens économique
biodiversité mais aussi la crise au sens
politique c'était interdit six autres
questions
julien benneteau missionné et la mise à
cinq billets et on sent le rapport d'
enquête a du mal à sortir techniquement
n'ai pas vu huy vers les pyrénées vos
lectures parce que je pense que le
rapporteur est présidente
ils sont pas du même bord que vous allez
l'attendait la rapporteuse c'est le lait
payé 1000 fermes isolées auraient
effectivement de la rétention
je faisais je n'en pense rien tout ce
que je sais c'est que le jour où je suis
passé à la commission denquête ils
étaient deux c'est à dire qu'il y avait
que le président et les [ __ ] 8 faire ça
et je pense qu'il y avait un troisième
qui est arrivé en cours de route
je suis au point de vue c'est pas parce
que j'ai envie de vous gâcher quelques
jours de porter objectivement dans la
halle aux vêtements je me suis quand
même je sais pas s'ils sont en détention
pendant dix ans y ont effectivement
maintenant vous le dit
il ya eu le
en fait moi je me pose à moi même nous
testions pas celle là qui est beaucoup
plus structurantes
je sais toujours pas compris pourquoi
est ce qu'on arrive au pouvoir
macron n'a pas jeté à la cheville
immédiatement les 50% de nucléaire
j'arrive toujours pas à comprendre mon
sentiment c'est qu'à l'époque le coût
politique pour lui était absolument
nulle parce que le convoi de gens en
france pour qu'il abaisse à 50% du
nucléaire et le premier petit gain le
trump il est déterminant des bulletins
de vote allaient 1%
je dis bien le premier lien je pense
qu'il y aurait quand même pas tant que
ça qui se dégageait du bateau mère de
par excellence qu'il est mort absorbant
de tout débarque c'est à dire que tout
débat dans ce pays très très vite tant
pour les milliards que pour les mesures
à prendre se focalise là-dessus et dans
tous les médias parisiens ça se focalise
là-dessus ça se focalise pas là dessus
en france et soit dit en passant en
allemagne que dans la feuille de route
qui a été donnée par la doublette
président de la commission à la
commissaire européenne chargé de
l'énergie
vous n'avez pas le loup pétrole j'ai
regardé hier par le mot étrange qui la
première énergie consommée en europe qui
est celle qui est déjà contraction suivi
d'approvisionnement qu'irresponsable la
moitié du co2 européens et a pas le mot
pétrole par le feu dont on se fout
qu'ils pensent que le gaz
il n'est décrit qu'une chose totalement
hallucinante qui est que l'on peut
continuer d'en consommer parce que de
toute façon d'ici 30 ans a séquestré la
totalité du co2 qui vient l'usagé du gaz
donc je vous annonce qu'on a séquestré
un milliard de tonnes de co2 de gaz
oui c'est un milliard de tonnes de co2
par an c'est le seul problème en ce qui
concerne le nucléaire
la feuille de route y assurer la sûreté
poursuivre le démantèlement est très
exactement top 5 c'est écrit donc on est
macron il avait une carte à jouer
encore une fois dans un pays qui ne
produit pas d'éoliennes qui ne produit
pas de panneaux solaires qui produisent
les centrales étaient pour le grand
fonctionne à peu près et qui de toute
façon
pour une fois on l'a d'étape il avait un
truc qui me gêne pour moi enfin un truc
sans peine qui étaient 10 rebonds voix
hollande et la verdad assurent les 50%
quand je m'en fous c'est pas votre
problème donc je vais peut-être que lui
aurait le ptb
il serait par le gouvernement s'élèvent
face aux lions parce que moi si j'avais
été à la place de yoann j'aurais qui
veut prendre tous on peut du clae l'air
du cactus vous sachez le verge pas
entendre parler
et s'il avait des lots c'est ce que
j'aurais fait parce que du coup je me
serai occupé de tout un tas d'autres
trucs sur lequel j'aurai fait bouger les
lignes
alors que là je me suis enfermé hulot
s'est enfermé dans l'élément absent du
débat donc il ya commencé à dire partout
qu'il fallait fermer fessenheim et c est
donc pendant qu'il faisait ça qui les
oppose
donc on est enfin vraiment qu'avec ces
savants la question que je me pose et si
le ballon avait pris cette décision au
vert or apple besoin de son accord du
père d'élise est de rentrer dans ce cas
je ne comprends toujours pas pourquoi
ap un coupé net en dix ans pour ce clip
tourne maintenant c'est trop tard pour
une raison assez simple c'est qu'on
vient de faire passer une loi en disant
vous comprends pas la jambe en 2025 et
rouleront en 2035 et enfin le cadre il
reste une connerie dix ans plus tard on
n'est toujours pas sorti de sparadrap du
capitaine haddock
donc on va toujours cette espèce de
débat et donc les antinucléaires y croit
toujours
il a regagné 10 ans les producteurs se
disent toujours on va continuer à se
battre parce que les portables et donc
on continue à mobiliser les énergies et
les cervelles pour un débat accessoires
en s'occupant pas du problème principal
donc 2035
c'est bio que 2025 mais le vrai truc qui
aurait permis de s'occuper des vrais
problèmes aurait été le supprimer ce
match arrêtent de dire c'est pas le
sujet du moment
je redis je pense à eux est dans le
c'est évident
question si à ces électeurs là on avait
dit écoutez le nucléaire on la regarde
mais on va s'occuper de faire des pistes
cyclables de l'agriculture bio de la
pompe à chaleur de relocaliser industrie
pour le fait est ce qu'ils auraient pas
c'est parce que je suis pas suivre dit
autrement ce qui permet d'un côté le
gagne et probablement de l'autre donc je
je je je continue à un jeu que je
continue à penser époux sûr que c'était
son meilleur paris nex sur le plan
politique joliment ses rôles et les
services d'éducation ou après
l'éducation qui est pour elle aussi
j'avais tant pour le marigot grand
moment de solitude quand j'ai penché
pour la commission environnement dans
les puissants marchés dans les data
sélection il jugé
je vais skier en bas il ya un sujet
qu'on n'a pas abordé du tout pourra
peut-être abordé c'est parti on a encore
le temps ces studios les clients de
quatrième génération nucléaire de
quatrième génération est en fait alors
je vais probablement l'arrêt du
nucléaire de quatrième génération est
une manière à peu près assurée de tuer
le nucléaire en termes parce qu'en fait
le nucléaire qu'on utilise aujourd'hui
n'est pas suffisamment efficace sur
l'utilisation du radium quand il puisse
être déployée à large échelle ont tué
une bonne partie du charbon alors je
récite un truc un mois je vais le
nucléaire que c'est une chambre s'il
vient se rajouter au charbon qui
n'intéressent pas donc fait toujours pas
des déchets raison garder mais en
attendant il m'intéresse pas pour le
seul lucas qui m'intéresse à celui qu'il
est très charmant donc le nucléaire qui
doit tuer le charbon il doit contribuer
à remplacer une bonne partie des 2000
200 gigawatts de charbon qu'on a
aujourd'hui dans le monde
on vient le papa samba quatrième
génération parce qu'il n'ya pas assez
d'uranium 235 pour avoir un parc
nucléaire pérenne pour remplacer tous y
vont oui une bonne partie de ce charmant
donc le seul nucléaire intéressant à
long terme c'est nucléaire de quatrième
génération de 4 absolument de quatrième
génération
alors pour ceux qui sont pas familiers
des générations nucléaire le nucléaire
le deuxième génération c'est celui qu'on
utilise à ce qu'en france les réacteurs
à eau pressurisée troisième génération
en fait c'est de plus un petit coup de
marketing la dent à faire c'est pas
vraiment une rupture lantern
technologique
par contre le nucléaire de quatrième
génération ils utilisent des boyaux
fissiles qui sont pas les mêmes et il
utilise une technologie qui n'est pas la
même alors on en a eu en france 2 1 qui
a fonctionné pendant 30 ans félix
enfin dessin fonctionne très bien
puisque phoenix qui est un dessin
exactement identique aventure et pendant
30 ans par cool on va déjà entendu
parler ce qui n'a pas été un objectif
politique bien branché cet incident a
expliqué
les chinois sont en train d'en
construire et les rues sont enfin
construire donc le nucléaire de
quatrième génération viendra devant
sinon c'est un fait péter la gueule
avant autre exemple on peut bien prendre